foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
it's Friday
and Texas is trying to
get rid of the First Amendment
apparently
I guess that's what they're doing
they're like ah that First Amendment
freedom from you know whatever [__] that
[__] the hell with that we don't need
freedom
do they do they understand what the
of religious practices and what they're
doing apparently Texas is trying to
force schools to post the Ten
Commandments in every single classroom
foreign
posted up on the wall now the problem
that Texas is gonna have here
is that
you can you can put the Ten Commandments
up on the the wall of the public school
the problem that they're gonna have with
the First Amendment
is that they have to remain neutral
which the forcing of it is not neutral
that is in violation of the First
Amendment
from the state of Texas now these are
small government [__] this is
what they claim we're a small government
freedom of speech First Amendment Second
Amendment and then
well we like the fifth amendment now
because it protects our our Cheeto dust
Cuban honor cult leader but they don't
really understand the First Amendment
I've been telling you this for a long
time I say it over and over and over and
over and over and over again they don't
understand the First Amendment they
don't get it they won't get it just like
they don't get the [__] Second
Amendment they don't understand these
things
[__] they don't even understand these
are changes to the Constitution even
with the word [__] amendment in it
so to
to expect
that fascist especially fascist in the
state of Texas are going to understand
our constitution the amendments to that
Constitution and how that does not allow
the state of Texas to do what they're
doing but
having said that if these Ten
Commandments go up on the wall what what
stops a Muslim prayer group in a
community from forcing the public school
then
to put up
a Muslim black on the wall or an atheist
plaque or satanic black a Buddhist black
what stops them where does it end Texas
where does it end Abbott huh where does
it end
that's the point is it won't that's why
the government should not have their
nose into telling you what you can and
cannot do what God you cannot and cannot
pray to
this is simple stuff that the founding
fathers knew knew and it's really funny
that this group of people who is trying
to force the Ten Commandments to be on
every every classroom it's not like
prominently displayed in the lunchroom
or prominently displayed in the library
you know they're obsessed with [__]
libraries and mass bookings right now
and they're terrified of [__] books
folks they're regulating the [__] out of
books these these semi-automatic books
are dangerous
they got they got pictures of the Statue
of David in them for crying out loud do
you have any idea do you have any idea
what what our society is going to have
to deal with with these Mass bookings
I mean there's semi-automatic books
running around all over the school it's
ridiculous so I wouldn't be surprised
them being obsessed with books and
libraries they want to post this in the
library but no that is not as far as
they want to go they want to go much
further
this is a sign of their theocracy it's a
sign of fascism this isn't [__]
rocket science this isn't hard to see
this is exactly what they want this is
exactly why
they want it is to intimidate the masses
spread fear
the show that they are the powerful ones
they have the authority over you and
what you think what you do and who you
are [__] those Ten Commandments [__]
them burn them break them put them in
the trash as far as I'm concerned
you have the Liberty to believe those
Ten Commandments you have the Liberty to
display those Ten Commandments
on your private property
but on public property especially in a
school you [__] Republican groomers
better stay the hell out of classrooms
it's enough of this stuff they keep
saying that that liberals and teachers
are are [__] groomers Jesus Christ
they're forcing their Ten Commandments
on your children
now you may believe the Ten Commandments
[__] I don't know and I really don't
give a [__]
I could care less if you want to delude
your kids Minds down the the absolute
delusional Rabbit Hole of Christianity
with the Ten Commandments
and act like that's the end-all be-all
and there's nothing in and of above that
but there's law in this land there's a
constitution in our Democratic
constitutional republic and it says that
Texas can take its Ten Commandments and
stick them up their [__] ass that's
what it says
and I I am I'm hoping that there's a
challenge because I I know that's what
they're doing here right
you know that right that this they
really don't believe
that they're just going to be able to
slap up the Ten Commandments on on
classroom walls and no one's gonna say
anything
that's what they believe
are that's they don't believe that they
know someone's going to say something
that's the entire point they want a
ruling on this just like they wanted a
ruling on Roe v Wade
and they've had these plans all along as
soon as they bought and purchased the
court they wanted
and they get the court they wanted
they're going to change this into a
goddamn fascist theocracy that's what
they're gonna do
they're going to take away women's
Liberty women's right to their bodily
autonomy and their health care and their
health care choices between them and
their doctor
they want to take away parents consent
to their children
they want to take away all all the First
Amendment right for you to read what you
want to read and see what you want to
see
they definitely want to get rid of that
they definitely want to get rid of what
your identity is they want you to
conform to their identity and especially
their God and their religion
this this is their move to go to a
fascist theocracy
I've been yelling and screaming this for
years
that their attack on trans children is
not about those trans children
necessarily they're using the argument
of the others to strip away your [__]
Freedom your [__] Liberty and your
[__] rights
that's what they're doing it is their
strategy they don't give a [__] about
the Ten Commandments in classrooms folks
these [__] people who have power
don't give a [__] about those
Commandments being on walls hell they
don't even believe them they break those
Commandments on a [__] daily maybe
even an hourly basis these [__]
scumbags
foreign Jesus would be disappointed in
these Christian nationalists
he was so far from a Christian
nationalist the the little Hocus Pocus
story they have about Jesus Christ so
far from
a Christian nationalist it's not even
funny but they don't care they don't
give a [__] they're gonna use the Bible
the Commandments they're going to use
whatever they need to use
to enforce their bigotry on everyone
else
that's what this is they got they're
expecting a challenge they want a
challenge to the Ten Commandments and
they want a ruling somewhere that says
that they can do this
they can force you
to conform to their religion their God
their beliefs
because they feel like I know this is
exactly what they're doing they feel
like if they could do this they can push
it further just like when they got rid
of Roe v Wade they knew they could push
it to this point to where a state
government is demanding that schools put
up a a copy of the Ten Commandments and
display it in School classrooms get the
[__] out of here with this nonsense
you you think that you think these
[__] idiots in Texas would be doing
this
without the reversal of Roe v Wade
and folks they're in a desperate attempt
here to move fast to a fascist theocracy
it's the only way for them to stop
liberalism
that's it this is this is the the next
20 years is their last stand in this
country for a long time
why do you think they're terrified of
the younger voters in this country the
other younger voters are they got them
pegged they know exactly what the [__]
they are
I don't know if you know this but gen Z
has a different way of communicating
than any other generation before them
and a lot of people say oh it's that's
why they're trying to ban Tick Tock let
them ban Tick-Tock do you think that's
going to stop gen Z from organizing
are you serious do you think stopping
dick talk is Gonna Keep gin Z from
seeking out information
on the internet are you [__] kidding
me
you know I I just can't under I
understate how or to tell you how
understated it is that Gen X
wildly wildly underestimated millennials
My Generation they were like oh
Millennials are [__] they're dummies
they don't know what the [__] they're
doing they're so screwed they're not
ready it's every generation happens
Boomers said the same thing about Gen X
Boomer's like oh my God look at these
[__] same thing greatest
Generation in the world said the same
thing about Boomers look at these
goddamn hippies you remember this it's
same [__] over and over same cycle
and the generations before gen Z
actually I think Millennials they they
feel a little bit like like gen Z
like they were the pre gen Z and the
reason why is because our entire adult
life we've been at War
our entire adult lives we've been at War
since we are in Junior and Heist Junior
High and high school we've been at War
at the Middle East over oil we know that
and 9 11 happened during our generation
and then the great fall in 2008 with the
Great Recession
when we all started our adult lives we
started at a recession the biggest
recession
since the Great Depression
so we look at gen Z and we're like yeah
[__] these [__] they're right
they're right
and we feel for them we know how much
doubt is put on a generation we
understand it we get it
but you you think just because they
banned Tick-Tock they're not going to be
all over
this fascist theocracy like what Texas
is trying to do here they're trying to
test they're trying to test our Republic
that's what they're trying to do again
they know that this is going to be met
with court battles that's the entire
point foreign just like every single
[__] band where where they are trying
to limit Women's Health Care rights in
this country
where Ron DeSantis bans Health Women's
Health Care
in Florida that's right he banned
Women's Health Care in Florida you can
[__] come at me all you want with the
with the abortion word but it's [__]
Healthcare [__] and he banned it he
banned [__] Health Care he's Banning
books Banning math Banning the word gay
and abandoned Women's Health Care down
in Florida
and this attempt by Texas
to strip away
Texas Children's right to the first
amendment that the government will be
neutral when it comes to religion
that
that is Texas trying to out Florida
that's what these attempts are and again
it's these driven by these right-wing
Nazi groups
these America first real real Nazis
they're loud and they're proud about
their Fascism and they're not going to
stop they're going to keep this Scourge
up as long as they have this court
it's what the whole purpose of buying
the court was
just seems kind of funny
that Harlan Hitler lives in Texas
you know harling Hitler the one who
contributed to Clarence who knows who
knows if he paid off Brett Kavanaugh's
debt I don't know that I have no idea no
evidence that he did but I mean it's a
good question who paid off Brett
Kavanaugh's debt
I don't know maybe maybe Harlan Hitler
hawked one of his uh Hitler signed
mineconf copies to pay off Brett
Kavanaugh's I don't know how am I
supposed to know these are questions
that the Press should probably ask
maybe we should look into this
but they bought and paid for this
Supreme Court Jesus Christ Do You
Remember When Donald Trump took the NRA
endorsement and 16. do you remember this
no one thought the NRA was going to back
that [__] idiot and that's the
earliest the NRA ever bought a president
that's right I said it the NRA bought
the Presidential nominee in the
Republican race
but it only came after the heritage
at Donald Trump agreed to hand over his
entire judicial appointments to the
Heritage Foundation do you remember that
he's like I'll go with whatever they say
whatever they say
just do that
the Federalist Society I'll hand not the
Heritage well the Heritage Foundation do
but the federal Society excuse me I
misspoke the federal Society is who he
handed it over to you remember that big
news it was when he was going to go with
whatever they told him
you think those two things
didn't have anything to do with each
other
but here we are in this moment
In This Moment
in 2023 years after
the Supreme Court Justices were bought
and paid for after Mitch McConnell
refused to even meet with Merritt
Garland at the time he was the Supreme
Court nominee for Barack Obama
refused
why do you think they rammed Amy Cody
Barrett down our throats just weeks
before an election
those judges were bought and paid for
folks
it cost a lot of [__] money to get
this court to where they could they
could proudly groom children in Texas to
be Christians
without the government interfering and
being neutral
they definitely want to oppress the
First Amendment rights of children in
Texas
and that's why they want to take away
your consent too why do you think they
want to take away your schools and your
consent so they can easily groom your
children into being white Christian
nationalists
how do you think this stuff works have
you ever looked have you ever looked at
a [__] history book
and just read a little bit about the
night late 20s and 30s in Germany I'm
not even talking about the late 30s and
40s I'm talking about the late 20s and
the early 1930s in Germany how this [__]
worked
just go dust off a [__] book or two
at the library if you still got one if
you haven't had Republican strip you of
them
this is how this works and that's what
they're doing is testing the system
and that's what this Ten Commandment
demand of it being displayed in
classrooms in Texas is
they're testing to see how how
conservative their Court really truly is
[__] that's what the metapress stone
drug is
there's other there's other health care
services out there that are in form of
drugs that provide abortion services
for women
they went after that one to see if it
would work
now that's apparently the Supreme Court
is going to make a decision on that
today
so Texas in the news baby as always
but this freedom freedom to tell me what
religion I'm gonna be that is not that
is not what it says you want me to read
the First Amendment to you here I'll
[__] read it to you it says Congress
shall
make no law do you hear what it says
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or providing
the freedom exercise thereof or Bridging
the freedom of speech
or of the press or of the right of
people to peacefully to assemble and to
petition the government
for its redress of grievances
hmm
no law shall be made
shall be made no law establishing
religion stay the [__]
out of me and my religion or lack
thereof
that's what it says that's the first
amendment and they love that one well I
mean
let's be clear they like a part of it
they like the part where it says freedom
of speech because they're like that
allows me to do anything and say
anything I want with no consequences
that's not what it says
it's not what it says and also it is if
you want to
um not respect someone's religion and
you're trying to make a law
that shall disrespect that person's
religion or lack thereof
guess what there are consequences to
that there are consequences
I mean something inside of me really
honestly
I mean if we're talking about if we're
talking about religion right something
honestly this this is what I read
because I'm I'm
a nihilist I guess I don't know
I just would love to watch them [__]
squirm
if if they had to put a satanic plaque
on the wall in every classroom can you
[__] imagine oh my God can you
imagine if they got a satanic black
that's that that would please me more
than to win the Battle of taking the Ten
Commandments off the wall
yes because I believe in politicizing
every [__] issue
and you could you will watch you would
watch if the satanic plaques went up on
the wall oh my God it would be complete
and utter meltdown of these people but
this is the problem
this is the problem they don't
understand what the freedom of religion
is they don't understand why you have it
they don't get it
just like they don't get the whole lgbtq
Community can have whatever sexual
orientation they want they can dress in
whatever attire they want they can dye
their hair they can wear wigs they can
wear makeup they can wear heels
they can wear girdles oversized suits
paint their face orange make their hair
look really stupid
and go out and say stuff like the
election's rigged
you have the right to do that stupid
[__] by the First Amendment we don't we
have the right not to [__]
believe you
same way as we have the right to believe
a religion or not
it's our Liberty and as soon as they
take your Liberty away from you
or someone else's Liberty they're coming
after you
it's not complicated and understand what
[__] Liberty is
it's the rights and the freedoms that
deliver this stuff to us
and that's where we get equity and
equality
it's going to be a long hard fight it's
gonna be a fun one though I'm telling
you it's gonna be a fun one so I I think
I think what should happen right now and
I'm making calls
um with this microphone now to all the
people who worship Satan in Texas if you
worship Satan in Texas just know that
your satanic plaque will will be able to
be proudly displayed in classrooms in
Texas now
and I want all you Christian
nationalists in Texas to know
that I can't wait I can't wait for your
Ten Commandments to be right next to the
satanic plaque in Texas in all the
classrooms you stupid [__]
I would bet that this doesn't get off
the ground what do you think
after you know
after something like me you know
give some like common sense just give
some common sense that's all you got to
do
that's all you got to do is just give
them a little bit of Common Sense and
start to sink in
but again this isn't this isn't about
they're testing they're testing how far
we are going to tolerate them taking
away our Liberty that that's really what
they're testing now again that was the
whole Roe v Wade thing and it continues
to be with all these abortion bands like
Rhonda Santos a bit Banning Women's
Health Care
in in Florida
and more to come they're banning dresses
I'm not kidding you they're banning how
you can dress
I don't know you choose you want
democracy
are you want are you on a religious
autocracy
which is it
you're gonna get to choose in 2024
hell you really get to choose right now
again right now is the time to engage in
your democracy this is a time to be
talking about it to ask ask your friends
I'm telling you I know it [__] feels
like work but and democracy is hard work
it's difficult work
a authoritarianism is [__] easy
when you're a liberal you're willing to
go to the map for your ideas right
if you're an authoritarian you hand over
all your ideas to one [__]
that's it you don't have to have ideas
you're a sheep you get you get to
believe you just get to believe blindly
whatever the [__] cult leader says
rather it be a Hitler or
Donald Trump whoever the cult leader is
whoever the authoritarian is you just
get to believe mindlessly what they are
that's [__] easy
and Maga has it easy really honestly I'm
kind of jealous sometimes they've got it
so easy they just they just have to
believe whatever they want to believe
and then anytime facts come at them they
just say oh that's not real that's not
real that's easy [__] that's that's a
good existence
but it doesn't make sense
I mean to most people who have common
sense know that they don't want [__]
someone else telling them what to do so
why would they want to tell someone else
what to do I mean that makes common
sense and I'm telling you that's the
majority in this country they can say
whenever the [__] they want
this country is majority Christian
nationalists and all that [__]
here's that's such a [__] fraud the
biggest fraud that's ever been placed on
our country
is that white Christian nationalists are
somehow the majority in this country the
[__] out of here not even close you're
lucky if you get to eight to ten percent
of people who believe that garbage and
the other two or three percent of the
country that has Trump support are just
q and honors which they don't even have
any [__] basis and principle in fact
in the first place
so bring it on Texas Bring It On
Republicans in Texas you [__] Nazi
fascist go ahead put your Ten
Commandments on the wall do it
do it
they always get out in front way out in
front of skis way out in front of their
skis
on these things Roe v Wade oh yeah they
went balls deep into taking away Women's
Health Care all around the country you
saw referendums in Michigan and Idaho
and in in Kansas telling them no you
stayed up get your [__] hands off our
goddamn Health Care you've seen in
Wisconsin they they were gonna put
another Supreme Court to make sure to
get into people's lives
and the people in Wisconsin by 11 points
said no we're going to put a common
sense [__] liberal judge on the
goddamn Supreme Court it's enough of
this garbage we want democracy we don't
want authoritarian theocracy get your
religion out of the [__] out of our
government
and keep it out of our [__]
classrooms you goddamn Nazi groomers
what's what's next what's next you want
a picture of your cult leader and every
single [__] classroom too is that
what you want huh
is that what you want
I hope that you're gonna get it
do it go ahead try us
and and this is a good point let the
meat rake baby that's right let their
meat rake it's our new moniker hear it
the Tony Michaels podcast let them eat
rake they are they are professional rake
stamps steppers
they are the world champions of face
plants
I I you know thinking of face plants
there was something yesterday that I
missed Marco Rubio oh man he had one of
the greatest face plants that he's ever
had in a video where he's blaming the
government
for gas prices and floods in Florida
he's the [__] senator
oh my God
every single weekday two full hours
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
will keep you on the lowdown of how to
uh get rid of these authoritarian
theocracists out there these crypto
fascists
oh my God it never ends they're not
gonna go away fast folks I keep telling
you this and you're going to be sorely
disappointed if you think that we're
gonna solve this in two years and these
people are just gonna disappear from the
face of the Earth they're not
they may crawl back underneath their
rocks but we're going to have to stay
vigilant for a long time in this country
until we get it back on track back on
the track of of our government rep our
governments representing the majority
ideology in this country because the
majority ideology in this country does
not want to force schools to display the
Ten Commandments in the classroom
whether you're Christian or not the
majority does not want that nonsense
they do not believe in this country with
the First Amendment under our
constitution of our Republic
that you can use the government
Force people to establish religion
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
welcome welcome
oh let me show you some of this uh
weird-ass double talk
Lord Darian theocracy [__] the other day
uh Nancy mace
the representative from I believe she's
from North Carolina I think that's where
the [__] she's from
um we played a video the other day of
her talking about abortion and women and
Republicans are really scared that they
overstepped their their
they overstepped the boundary of what is
the majority of people in this country
with Roby overturning Roe v Wade and it
created this snowball of letting the
most extreme people in these state
legislators and these Governors to take
advantage of banning Women's Health Care
all around the country that's what
they're doing they're banning women from
having their health care and access to
it [__] you you'd say whatever you want
about abortion it's Banning Women's
Health Care
the what we I'm telling you we have to
frame these issues right
we got to stop giving these people the
the [__] word abortion we have to I
know I know I know that's what it is I
know it's abortion services but it's so
much more than abortion services
they are Banning women's [__] Health
Care
they're I'm telling you they're banning
it
same way with this metapress Stone uh I
think that I think I'm saying the drug
right again I'm
I'm not a woman so I shouldn't be
[__] telling women what to do it's
between them and their [__] doctors
and these drugs are safer than Tylenol
and they're not used all the time for
late term abortions if women are taking
these drugs for late term abortions you
[__] idiots
it's not what it's for
and it doesn't matter what it's for
either you don't need to you don't need
to worry your your wrinkly old little
ball sack
representative mccuck from where where
the [__] ever you don't need to worry
your your little head about what women
are doing between them and their doctors
as long as the government is making sure
that that woman and that doctor is
creating care
and it's regulated and to be safe care
for that woman stick your [__] nose
out of it
so not for this [__] and any any man out
there real [__] I'm talking about
manly Burly oh Macho hmm oh yeah Macho
Man any Macho Man out there
if you're not standing up for women you
are a [__] cuck you cuck little [__]
I'm calling you out
I don't give a [__] who you are what you
identify as Democrat Republican
independent libertarian you stay the
[__] out of her health care that's hers
and it's hers alone
that should be our stance it's enough of
this garbage
just like it's our religion you stay the
[__] out of it Texas but they all
intersect this is all part of the same
thing
the debate over Governors Banning
Women's Health Care and and United
States senators the United States
representatives in the house in the
house wanting to ban Women's Health Care
or even transgender People's Health Care
get the [__] out of here
stay the hell out of Health Care make
sure that that it is regulated so it is
provided in a safe manner
that's what we care about
is to regulate to make sure it's
provided in a safe manner
that's liberalism but you know what are
you gonna do
but I have a couple Clips here uh but
Nancy mace now remember we played a clip
from her
oh I think it was last week or week
before she's out on a national um press
tour trying to make sure that she
gathers up this uh this Narrative of
motherhood it happened in a Twitter
space I was in too where they were a
bunch of dudes were baiting women's
Women's Health Care and there was a few
women in there but they were promoting
motherhood
and again this mom's for Liberty and
this motherhood thing it's all ruse it's
all a ruse and you can hear it in their
language they're like oh well we want to
provide mothers only mothers what the
[__] is it to you
if a woman wants it see they they don't
it's not about the [__] fetus it's
not about the child it's about
controlling the adult and what they're
doing
so they're saying we want to force you
to have a [__] baby because they're
forced birthers and then what we want to
do is provide you services so that way
you can remain a mother and you can be
the image of a woman that we want you to
be
that's what they're doing
they don't want to provide services to
allow women to have freedom I mean hell
I'm not against anyone being a mother my
wife was a stay-at-home mom
that's what she wanted to do she wanted
to be a mother as her career it was
difficult because we only survived on
one income
but that's what she wanted to do and we
we worked hard to do it
and some women don't want to be mothers
as their career they want to be a mother
and a lawyer and a teacher and a school
administrator maybe maybe give Public
Service as as an elected official maybe
she wants to work in an office somewhere
maybe she wants to be an artist who
gives a [__]
it's her business it's her Liberty
so when they when they sell this
motherhood [__] this freedom of
motherhood moms of Liberty and all these
conservative women out there because
what they're doing is is now that
they're banning exceptions
they're selling these exceptions as
motherhood that's what they're doing
they're selling it as motherhood
so when you hear this stuff understand
what they're trying to do they're trying
to keep you barefoot and pregnant
because that's what their image of a
woman is and that's what they want
well I'm damn sure not gonna stand back
and let them get away with this trying
to take away women's Liberty
not just of their bodily autonomy but
their autonomy all together because
that's truly what they want right they
want handmade stale they don't want
women to have it not and autonomy hello
they don't want to be independent
they wanted to be submissive
and submit to what their Christian
nationalist version of a woman is
that's why they get so pissed off when
people choose their identity and how
they want to identify that's what
pronouns piss them off so so much more
even if you have even if you have the
cisgender pronouns like me I'm he him
right that would piss them off what what
what why does it piss you off that I
identify as a man I'm a biological man
right
that's because they don't want women to
have autonomy
and even the simple the simple act of
putting your pronouns
especially a woman
in in your bio on social media that's a
sign of autonomy and they don't want it
because what kind of he her him his they
them are you right they get confused
they get snow flaky they don't
understand
when Liberty is given to people
let's play this uh One Clip uh we're
waiting for Gabe Sanchez to drop in here
um this is uh just the other day
and I tweeted it out
um
now
she's talking about Republicans winning
the popular vote and that's hilarious of
its own but listen to the listen to why
she's saying uh Republicans won't win
the popular vote but we'll talk about
this and that's what primaries will be
for and I'm looking forward to the
vigorous debate on the issues that
really matter and not just to
Republicans because if we want to win a
majority of Voters if we want to finally
win the popular vote in 24 we've got to
talk about sensitive issues which is one
of the reasons I've been so vocal on
women's issues there you go there you
have it Nancy mace she's highly focused
on women's issues right I'm going to
show you the rest of this clip but she
actually thinks that the Republicans
will be able to win the popular vote do
you remember the last time a republican
won the popular vote
by 2024
it'll be 20 [__] years
two decades two decades they have not
won the popular vote
do you know when the last time before
2004 was
do you know last time
come on folks come on understand
something
understand what Nancy mace is trying to
do here she's trying to create space for
Republican Republicans possibly Trump
to start to take a stand against
these abortion Bans
under the guise of women's rights and
motherhood that's what they're trying to
structure this thing
I'm telling you I
[__] sure whatever doubt me I'm just
telling you what their National
narrative messaging and I'm on them
I'm on I'm like stink on [__] all right
let's let's listen the rest of what she
says I want to hear our Republican
candidates talk about what they're going
to do to support women and families and
those kinds of issues because I come
from a very purple District a swing
District a Bellwether District but right
now we only have two candidates and more
may follow so to be determined there's
two of them okay so she's talking about
Trump and Nikki Haley but if you notice
when she's talking about
um woman and families right this is
going to be a slow walk by Nancy mace on
this public tour and I don't know who's
convinced her to get out and do this
public circuit
of presenting this idea of conservative
motherhood and how they're going to
support women
um and and she's even going as far as
talking about the exception of a wife
I'm telling you mom's for Liberty this
motherhood stuff the thing that they're
going to hinge on the thing they're
going to grab a hold of listen to me
when I tell you this is the exception of
the woman's life and that's how they're
going to prove that oh we're pro-lifers
aren't all bad we're pro mother we're
pro mother
well [__] me because I tell you
they're I'm telling you what they're
doing I'm telling you what they're doing
and let me let me show you
this is the same [__] watch this
the same [__] Nancy mace just
this is not too long ago you want to
know what watch this this is about the
Biden family corruption listen listen to
this Kook you think she's a moderate on
CNN right we just watched the tape she's
a moderate oh we need to provide this
and that for mothers and wives and
families and we need to really get our
heads on straight so we can win a
national race so we can win the popular
vote this is the same [__]
listen to this just left the treasury
interview
over a hundred suspicious activity
reports on the Biden family and I have
to tell you there are more vitamins
involved than than we knew previously
and every time you unturned overturn or
look under a stone
so much more you have to investigate
because
it's while the number of family members
involved and it's even the amount of
money that we're talking about in these
suspicious activity reports is
astronomical and the accusations there
and the source of the funding or the
where the money is going the shell
companies
prostitution Rings Etc
prostitution Rings Gabe Sanchez let me
tell you something this Nancy mace is
full of [__] when she go and I'm I'm
telling the audience look I'm on to this
this [__] idea of motherhood we saw
this stupid this stupid all we're
standing up for are you high as [__] no
I got so something's job something just
yeah I was like uh something is in my
eye hold on hold on hold on hold on did
you get oh you'd be right back yeah
laughs
he's got something in his eye yeah okay
pup pup pass there 420.
but
as as Cape Sanchez is in the background
um fixing his uh stoner stoner look
there
chips and Giggles every time okay so uh
this video by Nancy mace
q and honor Nancy mace listen come on
you're not fooling anybody you're not
fooling me I I know exactly I know
exactly what's happening when Nancy mace
is making her Rounds Around the country
trying to sell us this motherhood stuff
they're trying to sell us this idea that
they're not they're not all crazies
and then she's like ah I'm crazy as [__]
prostitution
roll and there's a pizza place in
Washington DC with a basement in it
space lasers I mean she's saying [__]
like that to her audience because let's
be frank here Nancy mace the video we
just watched was not for CNN to see it
was not for us to see it wasn't
it was for her crazy ass social media
followers to see and then when she goes
on CNN or wherever the [__] to sell her
stupid moderate motherhood message
it's a completely different Nancy mace
did you fix it did you get it I think so
are you still better no you still want
something oh my God you know what though
you know
I have to be I have to be honest with
you I almost always think you look
stoned it could be because it's early in
the morning because I tell you what if I
didn't have a few hours to get ready for
this show I would look stoned every
morning and I most of the time I look
hungover because I probably is here's
the thing I didn't even here's here's
what happened you know I didn't do
anything yesterday what do you mean I
didn't even do anything the the most I
did is I had I went to a buddy's comedy
show and I had two beers that's what you
had for 420 was two beers yeah I was
look this is what I was gonna do and
after the show I was like oh I'm gonna
have a loose we had high confidence in
you that you would partake in board 20.
don't worry I got a whole weekend to
catch up
he's like I'm getting [__] stoned to
the Bone I got I got honey in my fridge
that I'll do something with I'll make a
peanut butter banana sandwich
I hear you yeah I'm gonna do that and
you just gonna do that huh yesterday
well yesterday we had the show and then
I had meetings that I had to have after
that and it was just like man I had no
time and then I was like I'll do it you
know I have excuses you know excuses are
like and then I had to film a [__]
what was that oh so I was busy doing
that going there it was I was editing
and uh which by the way for those on the
patreon you'll get a new what was that
on the Trump digital trading cards
that'll be coming out later today so
check it out go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez then exactly but uh yes I will
I will partake this weekend when I have
some time my partner's doing this thing
she's got all Saturday it's gonna be
great I'm just home doing oh [__]
nothing oh so so Saturday's the day
Saturday's the big day where i'm like
yeah I can do whatever I want at night
at night we have some plans but during
the day I'm like [__] I got nothing
yeah so I I am
I I I I did the 420 thing we uh have you
ever seen the movie tag with Jon Hamm
and Ed Helm yeah you want to know
actually you want to know a funny story
yeah sure so uh I was at a spot in my
neighborhood
and I was having I was having uh dinner
with with my writing partner that I work
with
and uh we're sitting there and we're
having a beer and we're having food and
we're talking
and out of the corner of my eye I see
this guy walking with like a very kind
it was like a
I don't know like a loose
shirt a white like shirt or whatever but
the the body like figure I was like this
feels familiar right this looks like I
didn't even see him yet but I was like
the the whole like
uh the gate in the in the walking and
everything it just feel out of the
corner I was like oh this this person
feels familiar anyway but as it's as
that's happening I don't even look over
I see on the TV they have a trailer for
the movie tag right with Jon Hamm and
Jeremy Renner who by the way Jeremy
Wright is a [__] Avenger level
person right now I don't know if you've
seen the recovery he's done all three
months yeah well yeah crazy and and when
I first watched this movie and
everyone's got to go watch me it's a
hilarious movie by the way do you know
he broke his arms in that movie
what you know you know the chair scene
where he he's on the chair and he rides
and chairs down yeah he broke [__] he's
broke he broke his arms in that he broke
two of his arms yeah and well when when
because I knew it had Jeremy Rainer in
it but and I don't want to ruin it for
anybody but like when he shows up you're
like oh yeah it makes sense that yeah
he's in it so it basically yeah so
basically what happened is I'm watching
the trailer and it's on the TV and I see
this person on the core in my eye
that person feels familiar like I don't
know who they are but whatever anyway I
turn I turned to look and who
[__] weird
who is it
but Jon Hamm
really yeah so he lives in the
neighborhood so what is so wait a second
you're sitting there at a restaurant and
there's a trailer of John Hand movie up
on the TV and John hands I guess that's
what happens when you live in L.A
sometimes
I'll say this it does happen a lot to me
where I'm like I go to the grocery store
I walk around when you live wear
celebrities yeah but here's the thing
you have to live in different parts you
could live in different parts of L.A and
you're like yeah right
I just have and also might just be me
like I just have this weird oh so so
they so they're like yeah we gotta go
see Gabe Sanchez I heard John Ham's like
hey man let's go to eat tonight I heard
Gabe Sanchez is going to be at this spot
I mean again I have to say that they're
not doing that I can't confirm
I'm just you're the most interesting man
in the world
but I do have a tendency is the audience
hearing this are they hearing this Gabe
Sanchez is listen he's making the claim
that celebrities it's because of him is
is the reason why celebrities I went to
dinner dude I go to dinner I got Ryan
Gosling over in the booth next to me I
go to the grocery store I got I got
Colin have you ever talked to him have
you like say Hey or you know like yeah
like when I see them I say hey what's up
or whatever like oh I like you know
acknowledge that hey I know who you are
yeah yeah like I was I'm sure they get
that a lot and they probably get a lot
of the oh and they're like I'm sure so
yeah okay like I don't I don't ever ask
for like an autograph or a photo I just
like oh hey like they're during the
pandemic you're like hey hey Jeremy or
hey hey Ryan you want to take a photo
with me is that yeah you want to take a
photo with me take a photo with me you
wanna take a photo of me I mean like I
uh uh like I know you're here because of
me during the pandemic uh Colin Farrell
would do a lot of walks right right so
he would walk through my neighborhood
and he would always pass by my building
so I would be outside and I'd be like
you know working out or doing jump rope
and then I'd see him
which by the way he looked like a
[__] Bandit because he would always
wear a band like a black gray bandana
around his face right
and so he was like you know so I looked
like he's gonna hold you up at gunpoint
or something kind of but I was like yeah
that's not something like the old like
like the 1930s right yeah he's like yeah
basically that's what he did but when I
would see him outside because he would
do he would walk with another person
with his wife or a friend or whatever
but they'd walk around and I'd see him
and I'm like I was like oh hey Colin
he's like
okay you know but it's like you know
same at the grocery store or whatever
it's just it's it is
uh the the neighborhood that I live in
and near is where there are a fair
amount of people like I don't live in
Beverly Hills or anything like that but
um yeah see big stuff is like where does
Gabe live in Beverly Hills uh no I don't
live in Beverly Hills but where I live
and live near
um
uh there are a fair amount of people
that that traffic through there we'll
say
the fair amount of people you mean
celebrities yeah yeah yeah I mean other
people too have you ever took the uh the
celebrity tour where you're going around
and you see their driveway no I never
actually done that because that's all
you really see is just your [__]
driveways yeah I've never done that it's
done through uh I think it's like TMZ
has one of those yeah you know a lot of
the time like if I go getting a map and
you can drive I mean right if I go to
Hollywood and Vine I see their van and
their bus all the time but I've never
actually taken a tour like that before
right
the tour in Chicago the double decker
because in is it a double decker bus in
L.A to take the celebrity tour or is it
not a double decker bus because I've
seen I've seen the rock have like
Instagrams where he pulls up next to one
of them
yeah
I feel like I feel like they have a
double decker I don't know I see the
Vans they have these vans that like have
the roofs cut off right and they're like
a tour van I see those more often and I
don't know if it's because it's just
easier to take smaller groups around
but I feel like they have a double
decker uh I've just never
so Ida must uh yeah let's live there too
she's on Facebook Ida says I avoid them
and understand the Privacy thing yeah so
it sounds like you're saying that you
you know they'd want privacy which I I
don't think like that's probably why a
lot of the celebrities live in LA is
because they're probably not you know
because it's it doesn't have as much a
weight out there as like yeah I mean I
think also too just based on proximity
right like
La is definitely a hub for everything
like there's all of the networks are out
here so all the studios so if you're
ever filming a TV show that's
you know
um you know NBC ABC Fox like you're
gonna be in on a studio a lot and
they're all right over here right so it
would make more sense unless you have to
be on location which typically then
they'll go to Toronto or Ontario and
they'll film up there because you have a
tax incentive for filming right well or
something like are states like Georgia
have a good taxes and that's why yeah
yeah
well a lot of Netflix [__] is uh shot in
Georgia yeah yeah so it's I talk about
the Netflix series Ozark because that's
yeah and I'm from Ozark but like people
from the Ozarks knows that most of that
the scenes are shot in Georgia not in
the Ozarks and the reason why he says
lady Ozarks has a lot of Oak and Cedar
yeah and in the in the show
um Ozarks it's all pine trees because
it's Georgia so so it's not then it's in
yeah George is a big they've in the last
like 10 years or so or maybe even a
little bit longer but they've definitely
like built that infrastructure you know
uh
oh man well I've gotta I've got a clip
here that I want to show speaking of a
TV show
um
your favorite celebrity earlier I was
like wow this is something else
the Cyber guy needs to have a TV what
the [__] okay so I don't know if
anyone's heard this but Mike Lindell put
a bet out there if someone couldn't
provide evidence that he was lying about
the 2020 election being stolen and I
think you bet 5 million bucks now
Arbiters granted
um this Challenger whoever they are he's
definitely not a cyber guy might be an
ID guy but he's not a cyber guy for sure
he's a computer guy he's an I.T guy
right not a cyber guy right so he so he
he's the one who won this five million
bucks because he proved Mike Lindell
wrong listen to me when I tell you this
he proved him wrong about the election
being stolen does that stop these fools
hell to the no hell to the no public
humiliation wouldn't stop these fools
they're Shameless let's let's listen to
why what's the excuse that he lost the
arbitrary duration of the five million
bucks he bet LDS well it is
that is golf
here I am
procreated news reporters call me all
day this is the problem that we have in
this country is folks like this think
that it's a good idea to spread their
life around you know their pro-life they
think ah let's multiply me the stupidity
you know what do you know what's you
know what's hurting them though is like
um their offspring and their offsprings
offspring are starting to be like whoa
Grandpa's a little [__] up
yeah grandpa grandpa doesn't know what
the hell he's talking about he's been
sleeping on the wrong side of the pillow
if you know what I mean Gabe Sanchez
let's listen to your pillow yeah right
stick your pillow up your Nazi ass there
Mike Okay let's listen to what Mike has
to say about the person uh who who beat
him here in this bet
isn't it kind of strange just comes out
the day after Fox settles with Dominion
this guy's not a cyber guy I don't even
know how he got in there with his
credentials he has he's an I.T guy a
computer guy but he's not a cyber guy no
so so apparently I.T and computer guys
don't know how to use username and
passwords I don't know what the [__]
he's talking about I have but a cyber
yeah I'm curious to go and watch this
whole interview for full content you
want to torture yourself like that look
man I'm a I'm a [__] Massacre I love
to torture myself what did I tell you
man I got all I got the Saturday during
the day I'm gonna have some [__] weed
honey oh I'm gonna I'm then I'm gonna
you're gonna get high and you're gonna
go watch the Mike Lindell I'm gonna go
into bannon's world you know oh my God
and understand what a shitty weekend
you're gonna have [__] idiots Kitty
we'll see what happens I got on Sunday
to recover so well that's true but let's
listen to his end of his we weird little
explanation here of why he lost because
this guy's I.T not cyber or some [__] I
don't know let's listen well you say
well why did these guys rule against
this well three of the three arbitrators
are left Democrats uh we only had a you
only get a little pools to choose from
oh my God so there it is oh hard left
Democrats
so this is more of the we didn't lose
wink
but we launched wink
yeah it's uh actually one of something
related to this found its way onto
bonehead
oh really yeah it was a literal last
minute
last minute Edition I made to the
bonehead okay well you know what should
we just uh let me see let's just get
into it well let me make sure I don't
have any more I I had a few more clips
that didn't have to do with bonehead
that I wanted to go over here
now that's the Carrie Lake thing
okay two hold on I guess there's an
interview hold on I'm curious about this
yeah you've got to watch the interview
with the guy that proved him wrong where
would I find that interview yeah is it
on Twitter
what's the name of the game where do I
get that interview yeah why why you're
you're hunting that down I've got uh you
you live in California you got to vote
so there was no it's so [__] left
wing right communist stuff out here I'll
tell you a lot of a lot of Hollywood
celebrities super commies oh really do
they walk around with Kami shirts on I'm
a commie yeah they say I'm a commie and
then they go I'm with Kami
um both ways you know I'm coming and I'm
with gami so
um
there was a special election a few years
ago
um of a recall of Gavin Newsom do you
remember the one guy that was um 100
years ago it was last year was it like
yeah last year whatever [__] you man I
lose track of time here the only reason
it was able to go into a recall was
because of the goddamn pandemic and they
gave me more time to get the votes
required oh yeah that's right okay but I
know where you're going with this and
yes the guy the guy what was his name
Larry Elder right now who is Larry Elder
uh out in California too Larry Elder is
a talk show personality oh really who by
the way who by the way uh had on the
record said I don't have any plans I
don't want to run for office I don't
like because someone's like oh you
should run for a governor I think it was
a caller that called in and he or it was
something like that and he was like
we're not do you know he was like I
don't want to do that he didn't want to
do it no he said he didn't do it but he
did but then the GOP forced his hand and
made him do it
only to then
be embarrassed because he couldn't get
anywhere close to beating Gavin Newsom
right we tore him apart on the show like
every day like on a daily we tore him
apart and Gavin knew some
buried him in votes well he also came on
to Tucker Carlson which you're going to
show a clip there right but he wanted to
Tucker Carlson after
uh Nancy Pelosi's husband was attacked
with a hammer right and he was making
jokes and he's like oh well as soon as I
knew he was alive I knew that my joke
was okay I was like what yeah well I
mean it is Larry Elder if you know
anything about him you know he's a
scumbag but he thinks he's gonna run for
president I think this is the funniest
show I've ever I've ever heard of Larry
Elder say let's listen the Tucker yeah
yes I'm announcing that I'm running for
the presidency of the United States on
your program and thank you so much for
giving me this honor and this platform
Tucker's like wow I didn't do you think
that he knew that was coming or he was
like oh okay no no Larry Elder Larry
Elder had this in his back pocket and he
knew he knew that he could get some
national press but you know what Larry
honestly I'm gonna say go like you said
do it much yeah why not yeah [__] yeah
but Larry Elder was a fan I thought
Larry Elder and Donald Trump were like
tight buddies
in Mar-A-Lago a lot but maybe I'm wrong
but yeah hey Larry honestly I'm I'm in
favor of this man there's nothing better
than if we had imagine imagine the
chance and the opportunity for us to
have clips of listen to this Chris
Christie Donald Trump Ron DeSantis and
Larry Elder all standing on stage making
[__] sandwiches right oh yeah oh my God
hell to the yeah how delicious that
would be that's gonna be fantastic to
make sure Donald Trump is the nominee
and we can kick his [__] ass in 2024
but I don't think Ron's getting into
this apparently Ron DeSantis is really
flounder now Ron DeSantis is not every
minute that goes by is Corporate
Republicans
there's no way what the [__] away they
were they were I mean they were in big
support of him what just three weeks ago
these corporate big corporate money big
billionaire donors the donor class and
the Republican party they were all ready
to back him and get and get him in the
race to beat Trump but they it it just
it it fizzled it fizzled
um here's here's another clip I I forgot
to show yesterday speaking of [__]
the donor class and Republicans where is
Marco Rubio Marco Rubio is I don't know
not in Florida but he's bitching about
it let's listen what's happening right
now in Miami into Fort Lauderdale where
gasoline it's crazy yeah it is that's
your state man did you know you
represent that state Okay let's listen I
can't find gasoline anywhere this has
been going on since Sunday and they're
blaming it on the floods that impacted
whose day Marco who is they let's listen
let's see if you define who they is
figured and they're blaming it on
consumer Panic yeah people are panicked
because they got to get to work they got
places to go
and you either can't find gas or you
have to wait in line for like two hours
down the street you know what Marco you
know what you should do you should call
your United States Senator that is
representing Florida I bet that
[__] I bet that [__]
might be able to do something let's see
if that's his suggestion here then call
so call your United States
representatives and United States
senators not me because I'm not yeah
yeah I mean don't call the governor for
sure right well yeah he's definitely not
going to do anything [__] that guy that
guy that guy is way too hyper focused on
jerking off the [__] Mickey Mouse
pictures and running around the country
selling his stupid [__] woke ass book
that guy would if there was a call that
came from Marco Rubio to be like hey you
know like Ronnie we gotta figure this
out he's like look at the phone and go
hmm nope not gonna take that and the
people he's with in DC oh you you need
to take that phone call he goes nah I'm
good I don't know who do you think Marco
Rubio
endorses first do you think he [__]
do you think he debases himself and
endorses Trump first Little Marco you
remember all that [__] from 16. yeah
Little Marco with the water right and
Nikki Haley was out uh when she was
endorsing Marco Rubio and saying oh
Donald Trump's a bully and all this [__]
we don't need a bully in our party we
need Marco Rubio because he's a good
person and a good politics a shitty
politician listen to this well you're
probably going to run out of gas while
you're waiting so yeah people are
panicked and of course they're filling
up saying don't fill up of course you're
gonna fill up because you don't want to
make you don't know the next time you're
gonna have to make a two-hour line and
they keep saying it's gonna get better
but it's not they got to get this thing
fixed this is crazy who's there wait who
the [__] he never said who they is who
is they they they they they like
companies you need the private company
gas companies he needs to stop with the
whole [__] pronoun thing I'm just
saying he needs that those pronouns are
gonna super offend the megalodites
[Music]
or you know whoever it might be or are
you calling out like a specific
person like a politician right or or
politicians plural that you represent
the state of California the Florida
right like probably doesn't know any of
those politicians that's right right
he's like I keep trying to call them but
but but but but no no no no no one's
answering
Margo
this is the guy this guy who took five
million dollars of of Mike lindell's
money well he doesn't have the 5 million
yet right oh okay but he's he's trying
to take yeah yeah just five million
bucks
but he must pay I know I think that this
art this arbitrary board is demanded
that he pay him five million bucks he's
gonna pay him 5 million bucks
I I I'm just saying so I've I already
like this guy right I already like him
right off the bat and I don't even know
what he's gonna say here but let's
listen let's just start off here right
he puts this challenge out there he says
that it would have to be arbitrated and
you take it uh they again with the
[__] faceplants man so
every time these idiots are like yeah
I'm gonna put this out there and it's
gonna go great for me
Rake right in the mouth right in the
[__] face okay let's let's see get
all the way to the Finish Line what's
your reaction today when you find out
you've been awarded five million dollars
for Mike Lindell
well Aaron thanks for having me and I
think it was uh relief not because uh I
I doubted my own findings the in fact I
never expected to be able to show that
it was bogus data because normally data
analysis could take weeks or months and
I had three days but the data was so
obviously fake that I gotta say
something real quick this guy's got some
magnificent teeth doesn't he
are you noticing that hey he's got some
really good teeth I don't know if he's
gonna need the five million bucks that's
like a million dollar smile man I don't
know Mike hey man maybe you should use
that in your defense here if you get to
appeal this uh five million dollar
decision be like this guy doesn't need
five million bucks look at that million
dollar smile he's got look at that so so
what this guy is saying is Mike Lindell
challenged someone to take the data that
Mike Lindell had and to prove that it's
real or fake and that he will give you
five million Ducks bucks if you prove
that it's fake is that what he's saying
is that what happened here
yeah I think that's what he's saying
okay let's keep going and I spent a few
hours before I could show it was fake I
always worried though Mike Lindell has a
lot of resources a lot of money and you
never know I you know I think the court
system generally justices served but not
always and so I was never sure if I was
going to be awarded the money and more
than the money I really wanted the
people the public to know what was going
on well and and that's what you've
accomplished I mean amazing you'd say
you think it would take you you know it
could take you months took you hours
essentially
um that that's that's how difficult it
was to debunk to make the point
um Mike Lindell you just heard he told
CNN that this will end up in court do
you think you'll ever get the five
million dollars that Lindell has been
ordered to pay you
unfortunately I don't think so it would
be nice and I don't think it's because
of court I think if he does go to court
if he does appeal I think it's going to
be thrown out but unfortunately I don't
think he has a case against Dominion or
I should say Dominion has a great case
against him and Dominion of course is
asking for I think 1.2 billion
so 1.3 billion
I'm afraid he's going to be out of money
before I ever see my fight
let's just start off here right now oh
man I love this gay I love it he's like
yeah I don't think I'm gonna that
[__] ain't gonna have enough
money to go around my five million is
just not gonna shake off this guy oh my
God
uh Mike lindell's in serious trouble
when you get this guy on CNN like yeah I
really don't think I'm gonna get the
money I mean
Dominion Dominion's gonna have their
hand in that [__] pot no way am I
gonna get mine yeah no that's why I said
I was like did this guy get I was like
did he get the 5 million I didn't even
watch the clip so I mean they've ordered
the arbitr the Arbiter has or the board
is Art right but of course he's gonna
try to fight it right he's gonna say oh
I don't have to actually owe this and
then you know I don't know the whole
thing I mean the whole thing is
beautiful in the way that Mike Lindell
the guy they're like oh we should have
taken weeks I only had three days but it
really took me three hours right like
the ability to prove him wrong just
shows you how much
Mike linned out like dude he ran a
[__] cyber Symposium and then he did
another cyber Symposium and each even
even uh uh what is the [__] Watkins
when he was on the call for this he's
like my lawyer has told me I can't be I
can't do this anymore he's like this
doesn't make any sense uh you guys keep
just uh you know just coincidentally
going keep coming well that that's
actually that's not a that's not a bad
um point is because uh Watkins was
actually talking about the data yeah
right and and the reason why Watkins was
and his and Watkins for you who don't
know Watkins some some people
um accused Watkins of actually being in
Q Anon but who is Watkins Watkins and
his dad are the ones who started like
4chan and Han is that right yeah are are
we're a big part of the perpetuation
yeah now Watkins was on this call if we
can find this clip and the reason why
him and his attorney are like yeah we
can't can't go any further is because
they realized that the the data that
they had was stolen right isn't that
what it was it it wasn't that it was
stolen but it was uh here let me
yeah because Watkins didn't want any
kind of um legal liability well they
were when they were looking at the data
I don't know if they found that it was
stolen but they definitely there was a
moment where he was also finding that
he's like oh you just happened to like
every time you are asked to prove
the with with actual data like evidence
the you keep having Tech problems which
right is a bit a bit ironic at the Cyber
Symposium I guess they didn't have a
tech guy there well no no no no they had
Tech Guys and I.T guys they didn't have
cyber guys that's the problem you know
everyone knows
he's like I got my cyber guy taking a
look at this I got my cyber they're like
okay Grandpa yeah you got a cyber guy uh
it's a [__] Apple Genius you sentence
talking about
um God so so but but this I'm assuming
it's the same data that this guy would
have challenged right
yeah and if this guy was able to see
this data within two two hours and
understand that it was [__] bogus
yeah then maybe that's the conclusion
that Watson's came to you all the way
back in the first cyber Symposium which
it sounds like any data analysis
um would discover that this was all
[__] within the first two minutes of
looking at it yeah it's possible that
this is the same uh okay because I think
that's the same conclusion that they had
live on here if you can find that yeah
there's a few other things trending here
um what the hell is this puts out blue
with and I get I guess
um okay so
um I sat right and right David
representative David Trott is um digging
into Ron DeSantis now this is coming
after just days after Donald Trump
secured over 60
um endorsements in the House of
Representatives and Rhonda Santos
couldn't even pull more than two
um but I think he got three I think he
got the oh wow God damn don't make it I
think when I saw the number was like 60
something or 60 yeah 61 I think and Ron
DeSantis barely got three
um but David Trott here and I'm not sure
if David tried endorsed anybody but he
did say uh in an interview
that I said this is quote I sat right
next to Ron DeSantis for two years on
Foreign Affairs committee and he never
said a single word to me so he's a
snotty little bastard yeah apparently
he's rude apparently did you see did you
hear about Jenna Ellis no Alice you got
me interested though Jenna Ellis is now
getting thrown under the bus by the
Trump campaign
well the reason why is because she's
been going out there in public
distancing herself from uh Trump and
trying to get onto the Santa's train and
it ain't been working yeah there's a
whole there's a Daily Beast article that
I'm like part way through right now and
uh basically she is for her disloyalty
to Trump yeah
um and and she's being punished
quasi-loyalty to DeSantis right uh she's
now getting
um disowned by this right well I mean I
wouldn't be I wouldn't to be honest if
if the audience doesn't remember Jenna
Ellis's she's the one she's she's the
one who got farted on by Rudy Giuliani
and gave her the covet uh yeah covered
through farts right via farts
um she he you know he was saying and
she's like covet that's how it that's
that's how covered Parts work that is
actually where covet started Rudy doing
Yanni's farts okay so anyways anyways
Jenna Ellis that um that line sack of
[__] because she went around she's also
the one in Colorado she damn near lost
her license to practice law because a
judge and a judge made her sign a public
legal statement saying that she lied ten
times about the 2020 election and using
using her law license to do as such
she's been walking away from Trump and
she's been doing it publicly because
she's done it a lot in these Twitter
spaces that we were in she does not like
any I've brought it up multiple times in
these Twitter spaces right and she gets
very offended when you call her out yeah
she's like I gotta go I gotta go all
right and I was like what could you ask
her the one time you asked her did Trump
lose yeah one time I said I said uh did
try Trump lose the 2020 election
right now
and she went into the like oh yeah
she was like I gotta go and then I was
like oh God what a [__] loser dude
and then another time uh she was talking
about the
uh uh she was talking about elections
and how yeah she thinks she's an
election expert and she well she was
talking oh she was talking about
election Integrity integrity and I said
oh man the first thing I said I only got
one thing out to say and I was like look
I think it's pretty funny
that we have Jenna Ellis on here talking
about election Integrity when we know
that she was censured by the Colorado
State Bar
uh she had agreed she he had admitted to
lying 10 different times about
falsehoods about the 2020 election so
the fact that she's talking about
election Integrity I think is hilarious
I think is hilarious that we're even
listening to someone like this and then
she's like and she got all [__]
pissed off
well she is she is a snowflake and she
gets triggered really easy I'm sorry I
just bring in facts baby I'm just
bringing facts
so here's the um from Mike lindell's
first cyber Symposium when Ron Watkins
now this is an oan broadcast because no
one else would cover this [__] and
that's why o-n-o-an is in deep [__] with
dominion and and so is news match going
to be in deep [__] with Dominion
um and I think Steve Bannon and his
[__] billionaire class
um supporters were the reason why this
got funded but really honestly I think
Donald Trump Steve Ben and the others
are like hey
um we'll just let Mike Lindell use all
his money to support us and you know
we'll just trick this [__] crazy
lunatic into doing it but let's watch
how this people in the comments go
that's a big ass screen yes it is a big
ass it is a big ass screen let's watch
must have been put up by a bunches and
he said
uh that I should put out this statement
and
I just learned that everybody we love it
that you're talking but just take your
volume down a little bit right now
please thank you
oh we have a problem oh it's just uh my
lawyer my lawyer just called me Ty
Clevenger Mr Ty Clevenger
ah what the hell everybody we love
Colorado county clerk
and he needs to produce those hard
drives immediately and return them to
the clerk
and so this is referring to so you can
hear Watkins there talking about how his
attorney has told them that my statement
is from my attorney that you need to
take the hard drives that you took from
the clerk's office and take them back
see that's why I thought it was
considered yeah yeah that's what I
forgot yeah yeah yeah but there was
another part there's another part where
where Watkins goes every time you happen
to bring up like you're questioned about
showing the evidence you seem to have
Tech problems and so it seems a little
bit weird and I think it might be the
next clip if you go down okay and the
next clip from the uh from the thread
there okay
yeah okay I think this is it you need
name let's see okay here's here's the
next lip here
or is our County election workers bottom
line
great comment
can I can I put out an update really
quick to that last statement I had
are you showing something Ron
yeah no can I I just want to update that
last statement that I had about uh I can
never forget what he says for some
reason
that last statement
uh so the information that Ty Clevenger
received
was from sharana Bishop and now she has
informed Mr Clevenger that Conan did
have permission to take the hard drive
but did not have permission to upload it
Chris Bishop indicated to Mr Clevenger
that she was an affiliate of Mrs Peters
and now Mr Clevenger is not sure whether
that is in truth
all right so you heard the name Peter's
there Gabe Sanchez who is Peters do you
remember the name Peters in Colorado do
you don't remember the the the county
clerk Peter oh was that the one the the
one that was God damn you goddamn right
it is you goddamn right it is Tina
Peters is her name and and but but if
you notice there they were like well we
had permission to hold them right so
he's talking about physically have the
hard drives but you can't take the
information off of them the information
it's not the hard drives themselves that
were stolen it was the info so yeah Tina
oh yeah Tina Peters the chance lighting
up now with Tina Peters
um but this is Mike lindell's problem
right and this is the problem that the
guy had with the with the [__] data
and the reason well not the problem I
mean you know the facts provide the
solution when he was like yeah it took
me like two minutes to discover that
this is all bogus it was all [__] so
Mike Lindell loses 5 million bucks and
he keeps tasting the rake and I'm here
for their rake testings all day long
Okay so let's go to um let's do this
let's do bone end of the week uh we're
past a little time here but we'll try to
tick through bonehead of the week so we
don't go to six hours today
um
I got some business to attend to so
let's do this let's go to break when we
come back bonehead of the week
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slim Jims
skull
near on a Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
foreign
[Music]
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
it's Friday you're in the second hour of
the Tony Michaels podcast and it's
[__] hat week
come off the phone end of the week
but it's half week here at the Tony
Michaels podcast go to
theconeymichaels.com click the [__] em
hat link there at D Tony michaels.com
use the promo code
hat week 10 that's hat week 10 and you
will get 10 off your hat order at the
Tony michaels.com again go to
thetonymichaels.com click the hat store
link use the promo code hat week 10
that's hat week one zero and get 10 off
your entire [__] hat order hat we
can't we hat we we saw a lot of [__] em
hats this week ew a lot I didn't I
wasn't able to upload yesterday I was
still working on the uh the beanie so
I'll post it this afternoon that's one
of the things I have to get done on my
list
so everyone it's bonehead of the week
and you voted you decided who is the
bone end of the week we break it down
for you every Friday in the second hour
here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh bonehead of the week we got we got
several boneheads
um we were late last night too and it
wasn't because I was stoned I promise
yeah and it wasn't it wasn't because I
was not stoned either right well I
wondered I wondered because you weren't
like responding I thought oh he's over
there he's [__] he's like glued to
the couch oh honey oh honey
she look at him look at him no
um here is our boneheads of the week
Elon Musk Dan bongino
and speaker Kevin McCarthy where shall
we start let's start with Elon Musk
um I think that's an easy one right
that's an easy one he's an easy target
Elon failed
um his rocket launch but I'll tell you
something else that Elon really bit the
dust on because everyone you know was
talking about elon's little
um his little failed racket you know
what I mean blew up in the air did you
know
he lost like 13 billion dollars the
other day did you see this yeah he lost
13 billion yesterday yeah with a B
that's it you know how much that's the
amount of money
I believe 13 million or 13 billion is
the amount that he took the loan out for
when it came to purchasing Twitter
ouch
so so the amount of money that he needs
to pay back the loan for Twitter
evaporated yesterday and this is why
this is why when they say like Elon is
the richest man in the world or Bill
Gates or Warren Buffett or Jeff yeah
it's that's all [__]
it's all [__] [__] their money's
all invisible anyways it's not even real
like because within a span of 24 hours
Tesla's earnings are disappointing which
which means
um and I think this morning Tesla is
trying to move to get him off the board
um possibly remove him as a CEO yeah
they don't want him to have a vote this
guy they're like look man you're gonna
have to figure out your [__] strategy
here because you're gonna sink this
[__] so so he lost money in Tesla also
the SpaceX rocket explodes in mid-air
and they try to be like no we meant to
do that accidentally like what what are
you talking we meant to do it actually
they're true yeah they're trying to
argue the fact to be like oh well we
were just excited to have anything that
was up that was anything that was more
than the liftoff that happened at uh at
Ground Zero right right and they're like
and I mean like I get it right like
you're like oh this is just like uh this
is how do they call it a draft a draft
launch or something like that is how
they referred to it yesterday right well
they're gonna bring in however they get
yeah they're gonna be like oh look we're
so happy that we were just even close to
getting as high as we did that's great
however when you try to use Rapid
unscheduled disassembly as your as your
excuse right and then use three people
on a panel who are narrating to be like
man man today was an exciting day let me
tell you that [__] blew up in the air
but it's even better than we thought and
it's like dude okay I get it I get it
you're excited and yes that is an
accomplishment to get it up there it's
like the biggest [__] rocket that
we've launched or whatever
but also
from the get-go when you have like two
engine failures right out of the gate uh
shit's probably like what's going on
here what's going on it's gonna hit the
Shan fit is gonna hit the Sham well he
fit hit more Shan yesterday because
um some of the biggest oh wait wait hold
on sorry sorry I wasn't I was wrong I
said two it actually
according to the Sandman he said five
engines failed out of the 33 from
takeoff
yeah so there you go damn well he's
sailing a lot he's failing a lot because
this Twitter blue check thing this
Legacy blue checks all a lot of blue
chicks almost all of the Legacy blue
chicks went away yesterday
um
new Icon by the way
really yeah now it's now it's just a
single gold check
so there's a gold there's a gold badge
right there's a blue badge a gold badge
a gray badge there's the icons that are
associated yeah how are we supposed to
keep up with this [__] man then there
are the icons that are associated with
the organization that you're part of but
you can also because I noticed this on
on uh on Don Winslow's account
he has just a single like it's not even
outlined it's just a single gold check
so is that paid or is that that's paid
it says it's a verified a ver this it
says this person is a verified
organization
but I'm like he's a dude though he's a
guy yeah what the [__] he's not an
organization but also it's like
you know there was that thread that you
sent me uh I don't know maybe a couple
weeks ago where the guy was like look
Elon I'm gonna predict it right now what
elon's gonna do is he's going to try and
reinvent the verification right for
celebrities and they're gonna get checks
Legacy checks quote unquote No I came up
with this idea like what right you
Stephen [__] and so now you have
a bunch of unverified celebrity and
personality accounts on there that were
once verified and now they're you know
right I mean anyone anyone if you have a
big enough following you could easily
change your name and change your photo
and you know start tweeting as if you
were this person and no one would
probably know the difference unless they
knew that was the wrong handle or that
it was a different account right right
well and and this is the reason why
Twitter sucks right now and I say right
now because
I damn well better bet if and it would
be his the people he owes money to so
the Saudis mainly if his investors if
someone came with a certain amount of
money I don't even care if it wasn't
even close to 44 billion but if it came
close and they can make the numbers work
they're like you're selling you're
selling [__] yeah
um so my guess is I mean this is just my
guess but I would imagine within the
next two years especially after 2024
um there's gonna be people step in and
buy Twitter and Elon not only he said he
said in an interview that he was like I
won't sell for anything that's less than
what I paid for it so he was like I want
a lot of stupid [__] yeah yeah he's like
uh if it's 44 billion or more sure but
if it's anything less no and I'm like oh
man you're gonna be [__] what he
ain't getting that loss for a while then
he ain't getting 40. it ain't worth 44
billion it wasn't worth 44 billion when
he bought it it definitely it definitely
is not worth 44 billion after he's taken
over I mean he's a [__] idiot and
that's the only thing he's proved is
that not only is Elon Musk a goddamn uh
a cowardly human being and a liar but
he's a he's a [__] bonehead so it's
it's appropriate that he ended up on
bonehead of the week this week our next
one is Dan bongino
now Dan bongino for those who don't know
because he's he he wouldn't know him
unless I tell you who he is probably
because
he's kind of irrelevant he's an idiot
but he was a contributor on Fox News he
has his own right wing talk radio show
and the reason why you don't know Dan
bongino is because he blocks everyone on
social media that is not a simp like
literally I I actually because um people
think like damn mongino is are his team
is
um
so damn bongino he probably has several
tools Gabe Sanchez which would be my
guess that he uses to mass block people
so like if he's gonna block a b and c
this tool what what will happen is it'll
block all their people who interact with
them on a regular basis it'll just Mass
block so a lot of times people go to Dan
bongino's Page and like what the f why
the [__] did he block me I didn't I
didn't know who this person is the
reason why is because they're using
back-end Twitter tools to mass block
people yeah so that so that only only
Their audience sees their [__] because
they don't want you to see their stuff
because because then you can rebutt it
and if you rebut it a lot of these
personalities especially the snow flaky
ones like Dan mongino that [__] ass
[__] he doesn't want you to rebut his
statement because he he knows you might
come with fats and [__] so but damn
bongino is on Fox News Now do we got a
good clip
um I showed one the other day but let's
see if we can
um show a good bongino clip so yeah good
idea of what this [__] idiot is but I
don't know if there's one on fire now
yesterday I noticed Gabe Sanchez that
yesterday there was a
um a rumor yeah there was rumors that
other people were going to be fired not
contributors show host is that true have
we been able to sniff out of any of them
I haven't I don't know if that that's
all speculation so they're talking about
uh judge Jean right being which they
downgraded her that she had a show and
then they put her on right and then uh
Maria as well so you're talking about
Maria
um bartaramo yeah yeah so Piro Piro and
Maria are the ones that are on
potentially on The Chopping Block right
they're trying to they're trying to
remove and reduce any liability that
they still have at that well any
liability that they have
from non
high traffic
uh uh hosts okay so they're not gonna
you know so Sean yeah they're they're
gonna cut weight they're gonna cut right
because it's 800 million dollars Tucker
Carlson's fine Sean Hannity's fine Laura
Ingraham I think she's a questionable
one as long as they're still bringing
the money as long as they're still
broken because they're gonna make that
800 million dollars I think Laura
Ingraham is the questionable one I don't
know if she brings in as much money I
saw someone break down the watch like
what the viewers were for each of their
segments like Tucker Carlson's fine Sean
Hannity's gonna be fine but Laura
Ingraham if you actually look at the
audience numbers she might not be fine
well it makes sense that they're cutting
uh idiots like damn but also they're
gonna cut the women first that's right
that's what I was gonna say it makes
sense that women's going first and it
would make sense from their viewing
audience so why they wouldn't want to
hear from women they don't even want
women to have their own uh choices in
healthcare let alone listen to their
opinions I mean that's just the way I
would think that the fox in his audience
would believe uh decoding Fox News did
our work for us here she always does she
says now that Fox News has fired Dan
bongino I thought it would be a good
time to revisit some of his finer
moments oh that's how you that's how you
want to put it she says he talks about
the size of his penis unwashed smelly
Walmart idiots and some third world
[__] he also mocks accounts like
mine well then at least I have a job now
Dan bongino isn't going to lose his um
His Radio Show uh anytime soon because
he gets to say any dumb thing he wants
to do a microphone that's what allows us
to do it
um but he's no longer going to be a
contributor on Foxy's but let's watch
this clip that decoding Fox News put
together for us
listen I I may get fired from Fox after
this that's okay yeah I mean you think
this is some third world [__] right
here let me say it again third world
[__] objection yeah Who the hell's
denying elections elections happen
they're just not happening in a safe
secure way that's what we're concerned
about this is some third world garbage
that happened tonight starts crapping
their diaper who don't have to deal with
the problems of the smellies they've
said to people you're not the smellies
you actually built this place my last
name is bongino probably don't want to
tell him who's got a bigger crank
awesome you can plant a big wet one on
our asses we don't care everything's
been the Dipsy do fliparoos happen like
everything's been flipped in their heads
right so and ah listen you're great on
wash smelly Walmart idiots this no
liberal zeros out there who watch this
network all the time I mean some of them
in their only job is to watch our shows
which is kind of humiliating but that's
for another day
and there you have it the coding Fox
News giving us some I guess you would
call him his finest moments
did he say crank did he refer to his
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah also
but like when I
what what about his last name would
imply that he would have a big I don't
know well I I don't know bongino Look up
the word bongino is there a definition
of it just means big dick big dick
creature is that what it I don't know
what that means uh maybe it's maybe it's
the ethnicity component of bongino maybe
I don't know it's Italian right well
yeah but is he saying Italians have huge
dicks right is that what he's saying I
don't know I I don't is that is that
like well it says many of the modern
surnames in the dictionary can be traced
back to Brandon Ireland uh it says the
bongino
oh my God oh my God hold on what when
according to this yeah do you know what
the Nate and I I can't I cannot verify
this right now I'm only trying one I'm
only finding one One Source do you know
what bongino means
that's what I'm that's what I what what
does it mean well
according to this I only have one
reference right now I'm gonna go by this
and say because on the Internet it's
true
all right it's printed there it's Gotta
Be what does it mean the name bongino
means baby boy wait wait that's not that
that would not be
um the obvious
reason why the internet according to the
internet names.org bongino means baby
boy Jesus Christ so he's believes that
his name that which means baby boy means
he's got a big crank what is it with
these people and children in genitalia
dude I don't know man they're always at
the intersection of children and
genitalia like why are you guys doing
that
Yeah man they are are obsessed man not
anything with children anything with
sexualization having sex with kids
Predators should we be surprised by this
though no we should be a surprise that
Dan bongino is the fat that fox is
cutting over there because he's a
[__] bonehead so thank you Dan
bongino this is the first time he's been
on bonehead isn't it yep I had to find
it first it's your first time first time
congratulations to Dan bongino for
making it onto the bonehead of the week
and thank you decoding Fox News for
putting together that
fantastic I guess you'd call it uh
Montage of Dan bongino talking about his
Baby Boy Crank apparently okay so let's
move on to our special categories here
uh we had is The Honorable the
dishonorable mention because that was
the okay so let's do alpha cut first uh
we all know we love the alpha cook
category every single week and Marjorie
Taylor green cucked on herself this week
is that why you put her here is the
reason yeah she cut herself so hard
unfolded the chair put it in the dark
corner and sat in the dark to watch as
the cucking commenced because
um it was it was Dan Goldman and Benny
Thompson that put her in her place uh
let's see I I could probably just search
Marjorie Taylor green but the problem is
is it's been
about I think
Jason had it
yeah well so just look acen and just
green and you'll find Ace and green is
that yeah
oh Jim Jefferies dug into her too oh
here we go so I'm gonna I'm gonna play
that one too oh yeah there's small well
digging into her
as you guys know uh Jim Jefferies is uh
excuse me King Jeffries I always do that
Hakeem Jeffries who the [__] is Jim
Jeffery Jim Jefferies is a comedian oh
yeah yeah that's why you know yeah yeah
I I get it turned around Hakeem Jeffries
uh is great but here's one clip uh Eric
swalwell went after went after Marjorie
Taylor green then we'll get into how she
it's amazing when they can use their own
words against them right let's watch I'm
disturbed about a recent tweet from the
former president that says republicans
in Congress should defund the Department
of Justice and the FBI
I'm also concerned about people on this
committee and their own anti-police
rhetoric this is a defund the FBI
campaign effort again thousands of FBI
agents who work hard every day to take
bad guys off the street now this is a
campaign ever but I really think Eric
swallow missed an easy target here not
only is she wanting to defund the police
she's wanting to grift off of it as well
yeah like like you're you're not just
having a fancy little meme that you're
posting on your right on your social
media you're like hey come buy a t-shirt
you're Biden's FBI rated and ransacked
president Trump's home they've now
confiscated House Freedom caucus chair
Scott Perry's cell phone well look man
uh if you don't do if you don't commit a
crime then you don't have to do the time
right like if you didn't steal documents
that you didn't own then no one would
have to go into your home to [__]
find it
to plot I don't know fake electors and
overthrow the government and on the
election in 2020 well in 2021 January
6th then no one would have to look
through your [__] cell phone it's
easy don't commit a crime and you won't
have to worry about the FBI or the
Department of Justice coming after you
confiscating your property and then
saying hey you're guilty and you now
have to go do the time right well you
know what's funny about that is this
week not only did Marjorie Taylor green
continue to call to defund the FBI but
she wants the FBI when it suits her best
interest so she got cuck there because
here she is with Ali Alexander in this
Feud with Ali Alexander about my own
Annapolis and Laura Loomer Nick Fuentes
and she's in caught in this battle and
she wants the FBI to investigate Ali
Alexander of course she does because it
it's only for oh her [__] is only for
thee not for me right she wants to
defund the FBI when they're coming after
her but when she needs the FBI
and she wants them on her side now
here's the other here's the other reason
why she she got cut like three times
this week yeah it was crazy man yeah
it's uh it's a rough been a rough week
for Marge over there the petty Yeti gets
um handed her ass again here in a
committee uh hearing watch this as she
has an outburst and calls my orcas a
liar it's outrage complete outrage where
China is poisoning America's children
poisoning our teenagers poisoning our
young people how long are you going to
let this go on
congresswoman let me assure you that
we're not letting it go on we are
fighting this no I reclaim my time
you're a liar you are letting this go on
and the numbers well
actually I want you to ouch so here is
so just to tee this up for you here's uh
Benny Thompson if you guys don't
remember who many Thompson and he was
the chairman of the January 6 select
committee and did a fabulous job making
sure the American people knew all the
evidence that they possibly could and
then the tick tock and the real-time
events of January 6 and how Donald Trump
and allies like Marjorie Taylor green
tried to steal away our government and
[__] on our constitution uh by by
inciting a violent Insurrection but
listen to what he does here how he stops
Marjorie Taylor green writing her tracks
listen well no actually I want you to
take the words of the speaker down
so in uh making a ruling on this uh it's
pretty clear that the rules State you
can't impugn someone's uh character
identifying or calling someone a liar is
unacceptable in this committee doesn't
it feel like to you that representative
green chairman green here not Marjorie
Taylor yeah Mr Green here he really
didn't want to do this he's like oh [__]
man yeah you're forcing me to do this
because he's like well the rules do say
I mean if it was kind of gray I'd let it
stand but I what the [__] you want me to
do you crazy lunatic yeah
rules more than you you're [__] right
right so now I've gotta [__] all right
fine we're gonna play this game all
right right he didn't he doesn't like it
but he gavels it down watch and I make
the ruling that we strike those words
now notice his language okay if you if
you listen to Benny Thompson he says
take down now he says strike right yeah
which now dang here's where Marjorie
Taylor green really gets cucked by
Daniel Goldman right Daniel Goldman is a
trained attorney he's been in Congress
he's represented uh uh other other uh
critical
um uh committees by by being their legal
counsel he's asked questions as legal
counsel and impeachment hearings but now
he's a congressman listen to what
Congressman Goldman says about the
difference between strike and takedown
it's sorry just a point of order
legitimate question you're recognized
our thank you Mr chairman did you move
to take the words down or to strike them
Mr Thompson yeah sorry I just stepped in
to take him down
so that's what we did yeah yeah my
understanding is if words are taken down
that means that the the member can no
longer speak in whatever the proceeding
is that those words were set
I
yeah
personal inquiry point of personal
inquiry that's there's no such thing
shut the [__] up this time I don't know
if you guys caught this because this
this is the thing government's really
boring Gabe Sanchez yeah government's
kind of boring right that's why these
[__] stupid people like the sensible
sensationalize this stuff Argent Taylor
green bobert Getz Jim Jordan they like
to make these big moments for Fox News
and these hearings most of the time
government policies boring governments
boring budgets are boring this [__] is
boring I mean it matters it matters a
lot like these things have huge impacts
on our lives and our country's life you
know the the country as a whole and how
it runs and operates right ascending
policy but generally it's pretty boring
that's why even in this moment you're
like well Tony this is supposed to be
like a gotcha thing yeah see the problem
is she just walked into a pool of her
own [__] yeah because not only did she
Break The Rules now she's trying to
operate outside the rules and Daniel
Goldman is smarter than she is way
smarter than she is and has just I don't
know paid attention to what the [__] the
rules are so he he can do his
um what's it called that they're hired
to do by being elected what is that
called is it a job is it a job yeah uh
account it's a hard day a soft J yeah it
might be right yeah yeah I'm not sure
I'm not sure but she's trying to do his
job let's finish up here how she gets
dunked in the trash
uh when we strike uh it does terminate
the time of the individual who is
speaking so uh the gentlelady is no
longer recognized
laughs
you burn boom now again there is a time
and a place
um for all of you folks out there
um trying to figure out why you would do
why you would break the rules in the
Committee hearing because there is a
time and a place to break the rules to
make a point
um but it's not to get yourself silenced
unintentionally like that's not the way
that you do it she looks like a fool
because she is and she looks like a
bonehead because she definitely is a
bonehead and she's this week's outlook
on bonehead of the week now Gabe Sanchez
we have a special audible called for the
dishonorable mention and this honorable
mention is Donald Trump yup whoosh what
what was the uh you you had the reason
here in the uh while I pull it up what's
the
so reason for him it turns out yeah this
is breaking news as of right it's just
like an hour or so ago okay this is CNN
CNN exclusive text messages revealed
that Trump operatives considered using
breached voting data to decertify
Georgia's Senate runoff in 2021. well
well what does this mean so what we have
here is we have in mid-January 2021 two
men were hired by former president
Trump's legal team discussed over text
about what they would do with data
obtained with a breached voting machine
in rural County in Georgia including
whether to use it as part of an attempt
to decertify the Trump's pending State
runoff results
uh the the text sent two weeks after
operatives breached a voting machine in
Coffee County Georgia reveal for the
first time that Trump allies considered
using voted voting data not only to
overturn the results of the 2020
presidential election but also in an
effort to keep a republican hold in the
U.S Senate
so isn't that good so for people to
understand the tick tock of this the 20
the 2020 election gave us a runoff in
Georgia because Georgia state law okay
if you remember what happens is if
there's not a there has to be someone
who gets over 50 if there's not someone
who gets over 50 they have a special
runoff race in the state of Georgia and
so that happened
um in 2021.
um and and we know the result of that
now was
um uh uh the ossoff and Warnock winning
those runoff races
um so because they won that gave us the
Senate
um not not by one vote but by a
tiebreaker from Kamala Harris at the
time
um which also resulted in us having the
majority but not the entire majority we
had to seed some of the majority to
Mitch McConnell because it was a 50 50.
so we didn't get the full power of the
Committees which we have now because
everyone got out in 2022 and not only
said [__] you to the Red Wave I made
sure to put 51 Senators as Democrats
make giving them the actual majority
which gives them the actual power of the
majority now in the Senate
um so and and again the runoff race
um and let's see okay let me read this
here real quick it says here is the plan
let's keep this this close hold
um this is the former National Security
official working with Trump's lawyer
Sydney Powell uh oh my Jew man that's a
really bad name you know why that's a
bad name the minions also got their
lawsuit yeah now look I'm sure I'm sure
uh I'm sure Ben myzealous or uh popoc
can talk about this but I mean you know
one can infer from this that this is
[__] Rico charges man
like the connection between between them
trying to do this and Trump like it's
not like oh I made I made a I made some
perfectly good phone calls to Georgia
and it's a lot worse than [__] than that
man well I want to read this to you this
uh paragraph here it says the plot to
breach voting systems in Coffee County
coordinated by members of Trump's legal
team including Rudy Giuliani and Sydney
Powell as part of a broader criminal
investigation into the 2022 election
interference led by a Fulton County
district attorney finally will so it
really feels like we're getting closer
now there was some news there was some
slight news out of Fannie Willis's grand
jury the other day
um speaking of the grand jury now in
Georgia
um it seems like that
um they're trying to get some deals done
with state legislators who was trying to
prevent the state from certifying the
election they were trying to prevent
that process or to have fraudulent
lectures electors which we know is fraud
and could they could possibly serve jail
time but those State elector are those
State officials they've been trying to
flip them on this case because what
happens when you have like a RICO like
Gabe Sanchez was talking about here and
you have different layers and different
levels of these actors they try to get
the lower level to turn on the next
level and the next level to turn Next
Level until they have enough evidence
for the one or two [__] at the
top and everyone else has turned on them
and we had that evidence that people are
turning is because a one of the lawyers
of the defendants
um who was subpoenaed and had given
testimony to the grand jury the lawyer
was taken off the case and the reason
why is because the lawyer never
presented the immunity that they were
given to their client
um right it's lit it's kind of gray at
this point of exactly the the tick tock
and the facts of it right of when she
told and when because I think I think
the attorney is a female right yeah yeah
so basically what what happened was you
know for anyone who doesn't know like
let's say that the you know the other
side the the
prosecution is like hey for your
defendant we'll offer them this deal as
your law as a lawyer you you know no no
uh subjective kind of interpretation or
bias or whatever you have to go to your
client and say hey
legally I have to present you with this
option do I think it's the best option
yes or yes or no whatever but you still
have to offer that to them right because
now what's happened is
if the lawyer never presents it and then
the lawyer let's say goes back to the
prosecution and says oh well they don't
accept a deal
you're breaking the law there in sense
of your your client never knew about
this potential deal right then they
never knew that they could they could
get a deal of immunity to speak out and
flip on these other people right so
there's a big problem that's happening
there which is they were not privy to
this information this deal
and so it's actually legally is not fair
to this uh to to their how do you want
to say it uh
conviction we'll say
and so what happened is the lawyer never
presented said she said that she
presented and then now we're finding out
that oh there's more details of this as
to what really went on and so now she's
been removed from the case because she's
she's not doing her job right well I
feel like there's also there was also a
mention of like conflict of interest in
terms of another person well the other
the other problem that they have here is
it appears the reason why she wouldn't
present uh the immunity to her client is
because that would give her client the
the leeway and the runway to turn on I
don't know maybe a dishonorable mention
that we have this week Donald Trump so
it seems like Fannie Willis is getting
closer and closer and Donald Trump
should be getting a little more shitty
in his diaper about rather the state of
Georgia brings felony charges or not
against him Rudy Giuliani Sidney Powell
and others
you know what's going to be unique
because um everyone had this big Fanfare
about the 34 felonies and the state in
York and really I was like yeah that's
not surprising that he had 34 felonies
on business fraud the guy's been
committing business throughout his
entire life it should not be surprising
what's going to really be like you're
going to be like whoa God damn now I
don't know who's gonna go first Fanny or
Jack right we don't know who's gonna be
first Jack be nimble Jack be quick
please Jack and Knight this prick but if
Bonnie Willis gets there first right I
think the significant thing about these
two cases rather it's the the special
counsel's case
um with January 6 or the Fini Willis
Georgia State Electric scheme case
um I think those two cases are gonna
wrap in a bunch of people right it's not
just going to be Donald Trump going and
getting a ring now the documents case
has the chance of just Donald Trump
getting arraigned that has the
opportunity yeah right so if Jack Smith
moves on the documents case first it
could be just Donald Trump being charged
with federal crimes and indicted from
from this grand jury that Jack Smith has
convened but the other two cases the
January 6th and the Georgia case there's
going to be a ton of people being
indicted all at once not just Trump so
you're going to see him and a bunch of
other dumb [__] boneheads
sitting there being indicted and I can't
wait I'm excited I think that's gonna be
great it's gonna be great tomorrow yeah
I mean they're gonna be like oh this uh
this is political persecution again if
you don't want to be convicted of a
crime right and go to jail then don't
cry stop priming and if you don't want
them to be political crimes stop
committing political crime Jesus Christ
it's not complicated speaking of
Political Criminals oh bonehead of the
weak
Kevin McCarthy welcome my friend
this guy this guy always puts on the
Cheeto dust knee pads and genuflex he's
the winner of bonehead of the week but
what's the reason why we had him on the
pole yesterday for bone of the week it
was almost like there was something like
Republicans like oh we support the
veterans and then they just they don't
but then also it's like hey uh we you
know we are going to use the the
um
basically
uh we're going to hold the country
hostage right in terms of if we go into
if we like default on on on our you know
our situation right now right like and
then it goes into Wall Street and goes
oh well you know we've never did we'd
ever actually we we've done this before
and we do it when we we what was the
phrasing he said um introduce
economic changes I think is the phrasing
I could be misquoting but he was on
let's see let's see uh is this we've got
a small majority of America behind us
we're the only ones with the plan to
help save America let's see if this this
is on Fox news this morning this is
Kevin McCarthy probably face planting
let's take a listen we need 218 votes
the Democrats are not going to try to
help us but they're going to wish we win
we've got a small majority but we've got
America behind us every conservative
group has endorsed this is a plan that
gets it that saves US money and puts us
when he says saves US money do you know
do you know what that means when he says
saves US money he means we're gonna give
all the money to the rich and [__] you
poor people right like because if you go
you look at I think it was MSNBC right
that was the clip where he was on the
floor the trading floor and he was
giving the interview and just got
[__] owned owned by I forget her name
but the the co-host of the show uh where
he tried to go in and talk talk about
just well here I feel like we should
just yeah we should show that one we
should show that one
um let's see if I this is this is it
this is it right here
um this is where he gets called out on
uh how he voted three times under Trump
to push that let's listen and think
about it a debt ceiling is like giving
your child a credit card okay all right
well I'm gonna stop there okay so this
is the speaker of the house he's been a
congressman for a long time
this [__] knows who is the one
who appropriates the credit card and who
is increasing the limit it is it is the
House of Representatives okay all of
them not just this one this current this
national debt thing didn't just start in
2021 when Joe Biden was sworn in you
[__]
hold on hold on you're telling me it
didn't start when he came in office look
this isn't all Joe Biden's fault right
so in this example where we're given our
child a credit card the child in that
scenario is Kevin McCarthy it's Congress
they're the child him he's the [__]
speaker he was the minority leader
before he was speaker for crying out
loud this guy's been a congressman
forever he's the child with the credit
card now listen charge the limit all the
way up would you just raise the limit
full faith and credit of U.S government
debt but if you feel like you can deal
with the spending in other ways which is
totally legitimate so if you just raise
the debt sign do you think 31 trillion
dollars of debt the CBO has come out in
the next 10 years do you know we'll pay
10 points you did it three times in the
Trump Administration as we did economic
changes we never raised
that was like two trillion dollars she's
like she's like yeah you did economic
you did you did changes you added to the
[__] yeah you you [__] made these
Cuts back in 2017 with his jobs bill it
turns out that it as predicted you know
with people who are actual economic uh
experts and people on the left were like
look if we introduced this if we passed
this jobs bill and we we allow these tax
cuts like the people who are going to
end up paying for the [__] are the
middle and lower class but people in the
upper class the wealthy this you know
one of the one percent this this this
top uh uh the rich group you're going to
find that those are the people that
benefit because they're going to have to
they're going to end up paying less like
in the first year you're like oh look
they're paying taxes or but in the next
year in the following years those taxes
that burden is put on to everyone else
but them so when you go oh yeah we did
it you know these economic changes we
introduced and we did so great and the
American people want it and they and
they're so grateful and blah blah blah
blah blah well yeah the American
grateful the American people are not
[__] grateful okay we're pissed off
that we have to pay more and he's like
oh we got you know and then Kevin
McCarthy wants to pull this [__]
[__] later on where he talks about
inflation and and this and that and it's
like you you do you guys don't [__]
understand this do you like you
understand it to the extent of if we
pass these things
will get the benefit as as the wealthy
we'll get the benefit but we don't have
to worry about who pay who [__] foots
the bill later on yeah no because it's
them it's them it's listen it is for
thee not me my rules do not apply to me
they only applied to thee but let's
listen to uh
a house Republican here from Utah let's
see if he thinks that Kevin McCarthy has
the votes on the Republican side for
this stupid [__] this stupid [__]
budget that he has he's had months to do
this months folks ever since December he
had before he became the speaker of the
house to develop a bill that could be
passed um and Kevin McCarthy hasn't
doing it says Kevin McCarthy was focused
too much on putting his cheat on us knee
pads on on how to keep his own power
than to work for the American people but
let's see how this you you tall
Republican Congressman feels about if he
has the votes uh speaker McCarthy can
only lose four house Republican votes
and still get the bill passed because no
Democrats are going to vote for it
do you does the speaker have the votes
right now uh I I don't think he does
right now and I think that's evident by
several members
but I'll tell you Jake I think you will
I'm confident that he will the the
conversations within our conference
among Republicans has actually been very
positive so I know what it is here Gabe
I know what it is about not having the
votes what they did is they floated this
plan to see where the holes would fall
this veterans this veterans thing is
really falling flat where where they're
like yeah we support the troops but we
don't actually because we don't want
them to have [__] benefits so we're
going to strip their benefits away from
them like what the [__] so immediately
immediately everyone's like Jesus Christ
you people trying to do your budget cuts
and the first thing you go for is like
children's education and Veterans you
yeah of course
that's what they say right like you look
at you look at the well that's not what
they say but that's what they do right
well I mean you look at the State of the
Union last year's State of the Union you
had Joe Biden talking about veterans
right you had in the in the the [__]
uh pits right in terms of
uh harmful effects that are that are
that our veterans need actual health
care for right because they were exposed
to the burn pits and he's saying hey we
need to you know this is something we
need to we need to we need to think
about right we need to actually invest
in we need health care for our veterans
the people who have been exposed to the
burn pits
Lauren bobert decides to get up and
[__] [__] about how Joe Biden is not
doing that right and he's not actually
caring about the veterans and he let the
veterans die and this and this and that
and then two days later State of the
Union was on a Tuesday uh two days later
on a Thursday Lauren bobert votes no
on allowing veterans to get health care
for those who have been exposed to the
burn pits so you can see that they want
you know and I forget who the
I think his last name is Jackson the the
rep from
um North Carolina
I mean what he says you know does there
are probably some people who really do
believe this stuff right and really do
feel like they have to ask I mean the
dumb stupid [__] yeah yeah but then
there are other people who obviously are
looking for that that like 15 minutes of
fame or they want their little interview
on Fox news with Tucker Carlson and Sean
Hannity and so there are people on there
like Lauren bobert and Marjorie Taylor
green who get up and like [__] yell
like banshees in the [__] jungle at
Joe Biden looking for that moment to be
like oh yeah we're gonna get on TV we're
gonna get you know Spotlight we're gonna
be able to talk about this or whatever
and it's clear that they don't care they
don't give one [__] [__] about any of
these people any vowels any children any
parents any Mothers anyone they only
care about themselves and it's proven
when they say [__] out loud and then
just days later they vote against the
very thing they were complaining about
right instead of being a part of the
solution they continue to be the problem
right
well they they certainly are the problem
you know I don't play a lot of Joe Biden
Clips but
because of what Kevin McCarthy's trying
to do with not only veterans benefits
but Social Security and Medicare as well
um for the some of the people most in
need in this country this is the
president United States at us at a
speech at the international Union of
operating engineers the local 77 in
Maryland
um he was talking about the federal debt
ceiling and the economy on this issue
the other day
um and C-SPAN picked this up and then
again I don't play a lot of Biden Clips
but I feel like in the moment of of
making Kevin McCarthy the bonehead of
the week because he's not only is he
trying to cut veterans benefits through
his new little budget that he thinks Joe
Biden is going to negotiate with him on
but he doesn't understand what Jill
Biden's been saying the entire time is
that the debt ceiling is we're not going
to negotiate over the debt ceiling we'll
negotiate a budget but you are not going
to negotiate with me the president
United States or this debt ceiling issue
you're just not going to do it listen
[Applause]
but folks this is really dangerous Mega
Republican Congress are threatening to
default on the national debt the debt
that took 230 years to accumulate
overall
unless we do what they say they say
they're going to default unless I agree
to all these wacko Notions they have
the fall
may be worse than totally irresponsible
it would mean Cuts in Social Security
Medicare higher interest rates for
things like credit cards car loans
mortgages working people middle class
seniors would pay the price for the
entire economy would be at risk
America's never defaulted on our debt
which has accumulated over 200 years
let's remember the last Administration
alone
increased the national debt by 40
percent in four years yet every single
year they passed they passed the debt
limit every single year yes they sure
did and that's because they're [__]
Hypocrites and Joe Biden should take the
stance hey man you you're you can let
the [__] you can let the debt ceiling
run out yeah whatever you want to do but
you're not holding the American people
hostage here so it's your choice do you
want to do your [__] job for the
American people or do you not and I
think that's the right stance because I
think ultimately and anyone out there
that's scared of the debt ceiling
um being busted through I I think we're
not going to have that fear and they're
gonna Republicans don't care about that
[__] I mean you know they're they're
what they're doing right now is trying
to make a [__]
you know we'll call it like a
Mountain out of a molehill right like
they're trying to make a bigger problem
out of it than it I mean like yes would
it be it's not great that we continue to
add you know money to our total debt but
at the same time
that hasn't stopped them from adding to
it before whenever they feel that it's
necessary whenever they feel that it
benefits them whenever they feel like
they have the ability and power and
influence to do so because they just can
they will right nine times ten times out
of ten they're gonna do it they're gonna
benefit themselves they're going to
benefit benefit their donors in the
wealthy class that is backing their
party and when it comes to actually
supporting Child Care education mothers
just parents uh our veterans anytime it
actually does something that would be
pro-american right Pro the people the
constituents that they are supposed to
represent that oh no we can't can you
only imagine what it would add to the
[__] deficit oh my God we we will
never be able to pay this off we'll
never be able how can we even do this
it's like well you had no problem adding
3 trillion to it you had no problem
cutting this for the wealthy you had no
problem adding that to the to the
taxpayer as their bill right of course
they have no problem with that well
almost every single president every
single president knows what's at stake
if you if you don't increase the debt
limit in fact there's a previous
president that has a stance on this
let's see if we can bring him into what
his opinion is on this situation oh well
looky here wait a second I I would
assume that this guy is going to say in
this clip break the debt ceiling [__]
the debt ceiling to hell with it make
sure I think that's what he's going to
say I think that's what he's saying yeah
let's see let's see what he says I can't
imagine anybody ever even thinking of
using the debt ceiling as a negotiating
wedge whoa whoa whoa what what what okay
so yeah right there's a date on here
it's July 19 2019 and he can't believe
that there would be anyone on the planet
Earth that would suggest the that they
could use the debt ceiling as a
negotiation
[Music]
like there's a clip for everything with
these [__] idiots in there so there's
a tweet or there's a video for sure
there's something there's something out
there of these [__] boneheads let's
listen uh when I first came into office
I asked about the debt CLA oh yeah who'd
you ask some people who know about the
debt ceiling let's see who he asked I
understand debt ceilings and I certainly
understand right the highest he doesn't
know anything about it not a [__]
thing
and I said I remember to Senator Schumer
and to Nancy Pelosi whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait a second was he taking advice was
he taking a manga are you listening to
this what kind of woke ass [__] is
this he was he was asking Nancy Pelosi
and Jack Schumer about the Dead scene
because he knows oh yeah I know all
about today he didn't know a goddamn
thing about nothing he went to Nancy
bullish and Chuck Schumer said hey the
Republicans won't tell me what that's
doing is because they don't know they
don't have a [__] clue can you tell
me what it is can you tell me how
important it is and vital to our country
and our economy how important it is I I
can already see it in the room he's
standing in front of him and I can see
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer looking
at each other looking back at him like
Jesus [__] Christ like how did he
elect this [__] idiot right it's the
same reason that like Laura Loomer says
that Marjorie Taylor green didn't know
anything when she came into Congress
which again totally believe it yep
that's what it looks like but according
to Laura Loomer she was like oh yeah
Marjorie Taylor green contacted me on
several occasions because she was like I
I saw your you know your Tweet or your
post or your you know your stance on
this I don't know anything about it what
should I say and it sounds like more
Loomer was feeding her lines Laura
Loomer was coaching Marjorie Taylor
green on what to say a Known Unknown and
proud islamophobe as she self-describes
uh was teaching Marjorie Taylor green
about big Tech and censorship and guns
and international policies I'm actually
happy I'm actually happy that Donald
Trump took the advice of some smart
people over in the Senate and in the
Congress at the time during his
presidency and and made sure to raise
the debt ceiling three different times
to make sure we didn't default on our
debt so let's continue with the advice
that Nancy and Chuck gave him here would
anybody ever use that to negotiate with
they said absolutely no that's a sacred
element of our country they can't use
the debt ceiling to negotiate and he
listened to him oh my God hey moglodytes
out there hey you proud [__] trumpist
you [__] cultist out there did you
hear that he took the advice of Nancy
and Chuck three different times I am
waiting for I'm waiting for the video
that Donald Trump is going to release on
Truth social saying how we need to hold
the debt ceiling as hostage uh
collateral against the left Democratic
socialists so we can put it next to that
one guarantees yeah he's gonna have a
video soon enough where he's going to
say that [__] well yeah because as this
as this heats up because people don't
know about this yet right and why when I
say people I mean the country really
doesn't know that this is going on right
because this is just hammering out in
politics yeah yeah we all know about it
because we follow [__] politics here
uh on Twitter and online and in the news
and we we just know what's going on
we're we're very cognitive of what is
what is taking place most Americans
don't give two shits about what they're
doing Kevin McCarthy built Joe Biden
they don't give a [__] what those people
are doing but they will when the news is
like oh my God three days and you're not
going to be able to get a loan you're
gonna be [__] and they're gonna be
like whoa what what wait to say what you
what'd you say and so that's when
they'll start to pay attention and when
they start to pay attention then Kevin
McCarthy and the Republicans will get
off their ass and what they'll do is
they'll do some sort of stunt to say oh
well we didn't actually raise the debt
scene we saved the economy right because
Joe Biden who raised the debt limit and
now it's bad that's probably what is
going to train yeah and also you know
kind of just like summarize the
Republican party and Kevin McCarthy
stands on this again like you said they
had since December right they knew what
was going to happen they all agreed okay
we're gonna look we're gonna extend this
over and we're gonna figure out a
solution
and
like typically people like you and I we
can procrastinate doing chores you know
I'll mow the lawn I'll take the garbage
out a little bit later today or whatever
it is like those are things you can
procrastinate on those are things that
you can put off and be like look it's
not gonna
it's only affecting me right uh it's not
a big thing that I have to do that that
everyone else is dependent on this is
something that you cannot procrastinate
on this is something where you can't be
like oh yeah you know what I'm just
gonna let it
I'm just gonna let the debt ceiling
[__] Crash and Burn here uh just to
own the lives but also because I
couldn't come up with a plan that was
any better than uh than what has been
done before right I can't even come up
with an idea that's that can support all
of these Americans like veterans and
children and parents and families and
all these things like I'm gonna have to
cut the corners here and there to make
sure that we cover the cost and again
this is just something that you cannot
procrastinate on because it's the
[__] American people and it's also
the [__] country right all of the
things that will shut down if they go oh
yeah well it's gonna again can't deal
with the debt ceiling now and it's like
well what are we doing here you know
what they've been doing you know what
they've been doing while laying this
whole debt ceiling thing down and not
paying attention to the American economy
which they claim to be so for right um
is they passed an anti-transgender
athlete bill in the house did you see
that yeah well it's gonna pass in the
Senate but it's a ton of this it's right
[__] that they're wasting their time on
who gives a [__] man I'm worried about
Bud Light they're worried about trans
people they're worried about the gay
community they're worried about this
worried about that they're worried about
oh my God God forbid we care for [__]
mothers or or children or or the veteran
like again like it's all these things
like oh man [__] education we want to
abolish the Department of Education we
want to [__] wipe it out you know we
do need to do we need to focus on the
anti-lgbtq
[__] bill the bathroom bill or the
the athlete bill or whatever it is a
bunch of [__] weak
weak privileged white people
who feel so insecure
and so afraid
that someone that's not like them that
actually does represent
and and show does represent what the
country does is like is a compositive
that's what they're afraid of they're
afraid that someone like that is going
to I'm sorry replace them in their
position or or primary them or vote them
out right but they want to focus on
something that's like a a percent of a
percent of a [__] percent
of people that are like oh these trans
Athletes In Schools they're really
[__] taking over and they're
converting everyone
right like that type of it's that type
of crazy nonsense
is the point the cruel yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but they're like oh man they're taking
over it's like a disease this woke mind
virus is really turning me into a trans
person like if I sip this [__] Bud
Light I'm gonna turn into a trans person
God damn man it's like how how many days
we're going on like week three now week
four where they're still bitching and
moaning about this [__] Greg Gutfeld had
people on last night saying some crazy
ass [__] about just the the the
executive or the the VP I think it is
the woman who made the decision was like
hey we need to be more inclusive we need
to figure out
yeah the DI demon listen [__] them let
them do it because they're gonna lose
this battle time and time again with Bud
Light woke M M's and taking veterans
benefits away and holding the American
public hostage because they won't do
their jobs they won't do their [__]
job so that's why Kevin McCarthy because
he's a worthless piece of [__] and he's
a coward is the bone end of the week you
voted for him we just broke it down
let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
I really thought it was going to be a
close one you know what I mean it was
kind of closed there at the beginning
yeah yeah Dan bongino though man he had
like [__] five percent yeah
no one knows who he is because he blocks
everyone no he says they've done a big
crank but he wasn't cranking out a big
performance on this one well I guess
having a big crank doesn't mean you win
bonehead of the week I guess
I don't know maybe it's the opposite who
could really tell who could really Tell
Yvonne really he started out of the gate
all right but then yeah just like Tesla
just like uh SpaceX
[__] the bed
a huge a huge
unplanned explosion of Elon Musk on the
bonehead of the weep Pole thank you
everyone for participating bone end of
the week if you want to vote for bone of
the week make sure you subscribe here to
the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube we
put the poll there every week we also
put it on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod
that is one thing that Elon Musk didn't
do this month he said he was going to
only make it to where blue checks could
vote on post he said he said on 4 15.
we're gonna still shoot so that only
check mark people can vote and
participate because the Bots the [__]
Bots who would guess that elon's full of
[__] yeah oh it should be a big surprise
right everyone that's bonehead of the
week stick around we got a few
announcements right after the sound you
love the song I Love the song I like the
song Let's play this song foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week bonehead of the week
oh man
Kevin McCarthy what a [__] box that guy
is really an awful human yeah just you
know just terrible I mean then again so
is the Republican party they don't care
about anyone man those Christian values
really went out the door well did you
see the the story from Texas the lead
story today was that the Texas is trying
to force the Ten Commandments on the
wall of everything you know how to read
yeah well
but also do you know how to read you
know just that in general you know I I I
actually welcomed them to open this can
of worms right because I don't think
they've went and read the first
amendment like actually just went and
read it to see what it says and
understand that if you get away with
this right which I don't think you will
right if you get away with posting
the demanding to post the Ten
Commandments on every single classroom's
wall all's it's going to take
is one [__] to go you know what
I want this satanic plaque up on
everything [__] wall every [__]
one of them and Bam sure I'm sure
they're coming I want to see their
[__] minds melt as these satanic
plaques have to walk in the Elementary
School classrooms in Texas and force me
we've got to make it equal if you're
putting those up right you'll put up
everyone else the government has to stay
neutral which means that if they if they
have to display the Ten Commandments any
other religious item that they want to
display in a classroom has to be
displayed
I mean that's just the way it is and
Satanism man as much as it sounds made
up all religions are made up so it's a
religion I don't know you better be
careful I mean listen you're saying that
the guy up there exists that means that
the guy down there exists
possible I could totally it's right he's
that guy too so I'm I'm excited about
this honestly I think I think this is
more again I don't think it through
there's they're very short-sighted they
don't think about the full long-term
effects
so you're saying when they step on the
rake they really don't even see the rake
handle coming well here's the thing you
know it's like they make it Miss no I
think I I think that they step on it and
they go if I go to this direction which
they've already previously gone right
and then they're like I'll be fine in
this
okay well if I go right then I'll be no
if I go left right if I go right no left
the rakes are everywhere for them and
you know what's crazy to me is like this
isn't like unintentional like you know
like it's just accidentally because of
causes that are unseen to them like
they're like hey bring in the the dump
truck or rakes and put them all over the
ground before I start to walk it kind of
reminds me of you know when you have
like a a bunch of rat traps right mouse
trap set up right and once you let off
one then they're all like they all go
crazy right so it's just like one rake
and then it's a thousand rake yeah yeah
yeah pretty much because they just they
don't they don't have the the
intelligence or maybe because I really
surmise that that it's they're trying to
force a case to the Supreme Court with
this right yeah these are battles that
they want to have happen in the courts
right now that they have the Supreme
Court that they bought and paid for I
mean Harlan Hitler you gotta remember
Harlan here lives in Texas
big day yesterday so so Harlan Hitler
really wants to make sure that maybe
this decision of the Ten Commandments
goes to the Supreme Court where he can I
don't know pass uh Clarence maybe he can
buy like uh Clarence Thomas's uh bacon
lot next to his house and he can be like
yeah Matt's worth a lot of money and
I'll put a museum there one day but here
here's a couple hundred grand to get me
that uh Ten Commandment decision if you
want to come down and hold the uh
mineconf uh sign God I'll let you hold
it I'll let you hold it man I'll let
y'all hell you can even smell the pages
if you want
oh smells like fascism
do you think they do that like he's like
I feel like I feel like smell Hitler on
this letter like yeah I feel like uh I
feel like you know how like now like
Hitler the scent like old books old
books when you smell them you're like
right they have it smells like [__]
right they're like oh do you think do
you think books smell bad I mean I like
to smell like a a library yeah but there
are certain books that I think I think
moisture gets trapped in them and then
they have like that mildewy smell and
you're like Ugh this like this is
terrible so I think for uh it's probably
the same thing with Hitler's you know
Mein Kampf where you smell it and it
smells like barbiturates and sharks well
I think that but also it's like if
you're like man before I could never
really SM like understand the smell of
like a [__] ass [__] but as soon as
you smell mineconf you're like you know
what now know what [__] ass [__]
smells like right [__] the scent right
Hitler the scent I don't know which it
would be you know what you know what's
funny about the I said barbiturates and
shirts if you do any of the study on on
Hitler he took a lot of myth a lot of
[__] whoa he was on a lot of drugs
right and it caused him to be
incontinent and it caused him to have
the flatulence yeah yeah a farter like
crazy and they were trying to drug him
up so he wouldn't have the farts so much
he was constantly far which I mean some
days I you know I understand you know he
had the farts it happens we're here yeah
yeah it's just you know eat chili dog
the day before he might have the farts
the next day ooh they're uh you know and
then your cheat cushion starts to you
know smell like that yeah I'm not saying
I mean I guess I'm just saying yeah I
mean if anything I guess it's a good
thing that their uniforms are like brown
right exactly right exactly and that
yeah and but but yes so he maybe that's
what they're like we have to we have to
be the brown coats because we're gonna
cover up my [__] right right it would
hide the stain you know between washes
yes Hitler did have a it didn't have a
drug problem and yeah and Hitler also
had a shark problem he would um he had
the farts yeah apparently it was an
ongoing thing Rudy Trump Taylor I mean
farts everywhere there is everywhere
fashion flatulence yeah all the time
everywhere people it's hat week until
Sunday night hat week get your [__]
hats go to the tonymichaels.com click on
the hat store use that you use the promo
code hat week 10 that's hat week one
zero to get 10 off your hat order at the
hat store you can go to hats.d Tony
michaels.com or thetonymichaels.com
click the hat store link or the Buck Em
hat link and get 10 off your [__] em
hats for the rest of the weekend that's
week ten the Hat week one zero to get 10
off also make sure to subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast we're live here on
YouTube every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
nine Pacific follow us on Twitter
download every single episode every
single afternoon once I get it up there
and post it see what happens Gabe
Sanchez we do the show right and it
records yep and then I take that episode
and I edit the audio version of it it's
almost exactly the same sometimes I
gotta cut a few things out but I cut off
the elevator music on the front yeah
yeah they use space at the end yeah so
it's not that hard but I gotta edit it
get it all make it into a file and then
upload it to the interwebs for you to
download and you should download it
everyone in the audience should be
downloading the audio version on Apple
Spotify Google because it's free 99 and
also you don't need a cyber guy to do it
no you don't you might have to be an I.T
guy but not a cyber yeah maybe
definitely like a computer don't be a
cyber guy you've got to be a cyber guy
honestly all you need is a cell phone
you just download the whatever whatever
podcast directory you want to download
Apple Spotify Google wherever you want
to download that episode you can
download episodes of the Tony Michaels
for free it's also free to join us over
on Facebook at the Tony Michaels and you
can give us money for free games
maybe if you have an Amazon Prime
account you can use your one free
subscription on Twitch you just have to
link your Amazon Prime accounts to
Twitch give us that one free
subscription on the Tony Michaels
podcast and we'll get a few dollars of
Amazon's money through your Prime
account and make sure if you've done it
before in the past that you go renew it
every single month it's a little work
they're gonna make you work to give us
free money yeah yeah but you know it's
worth it
it's free uh you got it what was that
coming you said I got it what was that
that's gonna be I'm gonna I'm gonna edit
it sorry right after the show I gotta
edit through uh it'll be coming out
later tonight so people on patreon
you'll get the early access to the
episode that's about Donald Trump's
grifting cards 2.0 and then uh yeah I've
got another ones that are in the in the
backlog yeah oh boy these [__] games
okay well everyone go to patreon.com I
am Gabe Sanchez see all the extra
benefits over there from the what was
that show to the political parody clips
that he does the social media videos
that he does go check out patreon.com I
am Gabe Sanchez and while you're on
patreon check out my patreon page we'll
have a Sunday rant this Sunday I do
Sunday Rants and so just go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels to check
out the extra benefits there I
appreciate all my patreon members as
Gabe does we had a great time last
weekend on Gabe's q a and on the patreon
party that we did last weekend but this
week will be a Sunday rant so don't miss
it go to
patreon.cominkles and patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez everyone have a wonderful
safe weekend don't do anything that I
wouldn't do
same time same place on Monday serve
seven [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them welcome
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon